this is jocko podcast number 319 with
echo charles and me jocko willink good
evening echo good evening
as the seals inserted into a rice paddy
near where they had taken fire carl
nelson's
uh-1bc wolf gunship commenced a right
turn at 80 feet above the ground to
cover them
his co-pilot earl shot
worked the lz's edge with his mini guns
well as gunners petty officers michael
dobson and tom clavon fired their m-60s
the seals patrolled northeast and then
east on a dike separating the two rice
paddies
and then moved north on one
perpendicular to the first as they
advanced the enemy began firing from
well-concealed and dug-in positions on a
dike covered with heavy vegetation
the seals and nelson's gunship
immediately returned fire as the patrol
continued closer toward the tree line
the seals took accurate withering fire
from both sides of the dike
point man james rowland fell shot
through the groin he was hit again as he
crawled for cover seconds later the
platoon commander grant telfer was shot
in both legs
both seals managed to return fire
despite their wounds but the severity of
their injuries and the immediate
necessity to extract them soon
took them out of action
lieutenant jg tom richards immediately
radioed carl nelson and his sea wolf for
fire support as he and his fellow seal
gary lawrence advanced under fire to
assist the two seriously wounded seals
as he dragged roland to cover one round
passed through richard's right hand
hitting the stoner's pistol grip
nevertheless
while lawrence wendell hedge and donald
fruttrell returned fire richards
continued to expose himself to enemy
fire to drag the wounded to cover
when the automatic weapons man futrell
was shot in the chest he cried out i'm
hit i'm hit
richard's sensing the rising panic in
futrell's voice suspected the man was
going into shock
to distract him richards ordered futrel
to shut up and return fire
futrel briefly did so with his m-60 and
did not go into shock
as futrell became semi-conscious
richards pulled him back as well
when lawrence and hedge ran out of
ammunition minutes later richards passed
them the linked 556 ammo for his now
inoperable stoner
the squad regrouped behind a dike and
richards urged the seals to keep pouring
fire into the enemy as he radioed for
emergency extraction
when lawrence and hedge ran out of
ammunition minutes later as the battle
raged
extraction became imperative
including himself richards had four
wounded men three of them critical
for pilot carl nelson
and the sea wolves helicopter squadron
flying in support of the seals there was
no hesitation
and here's a quote from him
my crew knew that leaving anyone behind
was not an option
when nelson saw richards dragging the
wounded seals to cover he alerted the
transport helicopter flown by lieutenant
jg edward dyer to get ready for
extraction and descended to cover it
from an altitude of about 50 to 70 feet
from the ground seals
lawrence and hedge providing covering
fire with their stoners nelson's gunship
hit the enemy with devastating rocket
and mini fire minigun fire while dyer
urgently searched for the seal's exact
location
on his second pass dyer spotted them
huddled next to a dyke and came in hot
bleeding off air speed during his
approach
as the slick hovered skids wet in a rice
paddy richards dragged each of the three
wounded seals in turn over the dike then
through the rice paddy to the helicopter
lifting each aboard with his one good
hand
richards later wrote with one hand it
was probably the heaviest lift i ever
made
the best one too
enemy fire intensified during the
loading lawrence still providing cover
fire was about to climb aboard when dyer
began to pull pitch for liftoff as enemy
rounds hit the fuselage
lawrence grabbed the slick skid and held
on for dear life
until lieutenant jg richards reached
down with his uninjured hand and hauled
lawrence aboard
for richard's action and disregard for
his own personal safety the officer in
charge of seal team one detachment golf
telfer's immediate superior recommended
him for the silver
star the award recommendations summary
of action stated quote
without the conspicuous gallantry and
cool perseverance of lieutenant j.g
richards it is doubtful that the patrol
could have survived
the next senior officer in the chain of
command located at navy special warfare
group vietnam and saigon endorsed the
recommendation
inexplicably
the chief of staff for the commander u.s
naval forces vietnam downgraded the
award to a bronze star
that staff went so far as to change the
wording cited in the original summary of
action
the citation for the downgraded bronze
star now read lieutenant junior grade
richards courage under fire cool
professionalism and devotion to duty
were in keeping with the highest
traditions of the united states naval
service
such a substantive change in wording
undermined the rationale for the higher
award
it remain it remains unclear why the
chief of staff located more than 150
miles from the battlefield made such an
unusual decision
no explanation was ever given
the honor and recognition
that were earned that day but not
granted still rankles many of the seals
and sea wolves who along with richards
risked everything to save first squad
from certain destruction
some have even argued that his original
award recommendation should have been
upgraded to a navy cross
as carl nelson
and edward dyer were awarded
distinguished flying crosses pointing
out that richard's extraordinary heroism
under fire at great personal risk with
total disregard for his own life mirrors
that of those recommended for higher
awards
seawolf pilot carl nelson
who is on this podcast
number 288 expresses the sentiment's
best having flown more than 600 combat
missions with scores of those flights in
direct support of two seal teams nelson
vividly remembers the scene unfolding
below his gunship as the wounded platoon
struggled to survive
nelson recalls quote
watching a wounded tom richards under
intense enemy fire drag each of his
wounded seals to safety across a series
of rice paddy dykes and load them onto
the sea lord hilo it was the most heroic
act that i have ever witnessed
tom richard's heroism rates a navy cross
at minimum
he directly saved the lives of his
platoon
now that right there
is from an article from naval history
magazine was written in april of 2020 by
a guy named captain michael g slattery
in another section of the article they
give us some more some more details some
more background on lieutenant jg tom
richards
and it says christened the hulk by his
fellow seals tom richards was well liked
and respected
and he enjoyed a reputation as a highly
capable operator
he was a native of brightwaters new york
a graduate of bayshore high school where
he wrestled and played football
following graduation he attended
villanova university on a navy rotc
scholarship there he lifted weights and
routinely bench press 400 pounds
he was commissioned an ensign in the
naval reserve in 1969.
while still a midshipman at villanova
richards was accepted to basic
underwater demolition seal training when
he began the rigorous program with class
54 the six foot tall richards weighs 235
pounds
he graduated 10 months later with class
55 at a lean and hard 215 pounds
he was assigned to seal team one in
coronado california
so that's what the article focuses on
talking about that one day in vietnam
but the
hulk
continued to serve in the seal teams
and if you
follow his career forward
from that event in 1971
and you go forward about 20 years to
1991 i was a new guy at seal team one
i didn't even have my trident yet i
wasn't even an official seal i graduated
buds but i hadn't got my trident yet it
was a saturday morning
and i was in the gym by myself and i was
smashing some weights
and i was blasting
metallica on the stereo system and this
was a time at seal team one where there
was a five-disc cd
player
and the entire thing was filled with all
the metallica albums at that time there
were five and it was locked shut so the
only thing you could list you had no
choice you were just going to listen to
metallica so i'm in there i've got the
music cranked up to an unhealthy level
and in walks
captain richards the hulk now he's a
full captain he'd just taken over as the
commanding officer buds actually took
over before i graduated so we all knew
who he was
and i immediately i'm a junior enlisted
i immediately run over and i turn down
the stereo
because i don't want to bother the
senior officer
and as i turn down the stereo
captain rich is just me and him in there
on a saturday morning
captain richards goes hey
and i look over
and he says
turn that [ __ ] back up
and so i did
and worked out and
he was working out and we were throwing
weight around and he was throwing around
more weight than me by the way i doubt
that
uh
and then you fast forward a little bit
further i think it was 1996 or 1997. it
was 1997
and now i meet the hulk again now only
now he's the admiral he's in charge of
all the seals
and he interviewed me
and wrote me a recommendation to become
a seal officer
and i got accepted into that program
and carried on with the rest of my
career but never forgot the impression
that admiral richards left on me
and on the seal community and it's an
honor to have him here tonight to share
some of his experiences some of his
stories some of his lessons learned from
a 30-year career
in the seal teams
admiral
thanks for coming by
well jocko thanks for having me here uh
when i sit here and listen to
those excerpts from michael slattery's
article that
takes me back to those rice paddies
and
it is a day that i would have to
describe as
one of the worst days in my entire naval
career had to be the worst day
but i also tell you it was the best
[ __ ] day
because i got those guys
i got those guys
out of the kill zone
over to the protection of the dyke
and then into the helo
yeah i was a big strong guy
there's something called uh adrenaline
rush adrenaline high and all that other
stuff and you know maybe you could uh
you help some you know you know limp
dick uh you know pencil neck geek uh you
drag some of those guys across the rice
paddy but i seriously often doubt it
thankfully it was me who was only
wounded in one hand
and i was able to drag those guys out of
there
listening to
carl nelson
make those
gun runs
i don't know if there's any car nuts in
the room or listening in here but
one of my roommates in villanova had a
1967 corvette 427 425 damn horsepower
and when skip stood on that thing
i believe he had a couple of cutouts
legal or not but when skip stood on that
sucker
it roared well
that is the closest sound that i can
describe to those who haven't been there
when a minigun rips off and lights off
and that was one of the most beautiful
sounds that i've ever heard
so
as i'm
going back and forth uh
grant telfer and his uh uh
his update to the uh to the award
recommendation uh you know use those
terms that you used in the article
without regard to uh to my own personal
safety or my life
uh
i have to tell you that i never gave a
thought
to anything
but my teammates
who were
grant was shot in both legs
rock jim roland
shot
in the chest and the groin
and of course
jim's major concern with those injuries
was
would the equipment never work again
uh
and then uh you know you you mentioned
how uh
don futrell was getting ready to go into
shock uh
you know
i'd never been trained about what
somebody going into shock sounds like or
doesn't uh i had no clue but as soon as
i heard don
and uh you know you could hear his voice
going up a few octaves uh he referred to
it and
a note to me about his girly voice you
know hey don you were just shot in the
damn chest uh and uh you you got a right
to be you know you know going into panic
or whatever it is i didn't we didn't
have that conversation this is flashing
through my mind uh but uh i could hear
it and i just said you know it just came
to me
get his mind off his situation and get
it back on to our situation uh
i didn't realize how badly he was
injured and that he was going to be
useless as tits on a boar hog after that
but you know i just wanted to get him
back into action uh and and out of out
of any shock because you know we're
we're in the middle of nowhere and i
have no idea how if we're even going to
get out of there and if we get out of
there how long it's going to take and so
on and so forth so uh you know just the
uh
the great training from the
legends and seal team one before i got
there you know that we used to call it
seal basic indoctrination training and
then we'd go through a pre-deployment uh
training program but uh those uh who uh
set the history of seal team one before
i got there
uh those guys
made all the uh made all the difference
in the training and my reaction and
everybody else's reaction in the in the
rice paddy so as i was saying it was the
best of days and it was the worst of
days uh you know thank god everybody got
out of there uh
i don't know how often it happens but
i'm willing to bet not very often
both roland and futrell when they were
shot in the chest
the bullets passed front to back
didn't touch a bone you just went
through soft tissue and the uh the heat
of the round actually uh cauterized the
uh cauterize the injury uh those guys
you know who are you know
goddamn lucky is is all i can say of
course i didn't know that at the time uh
and uh
you know uh it was just uh just a real
uh a real
uh you know crappy situation but uh as
those guys got wounded you know my you
know my focus became we gotta get out of
dodge you know we gotta just get the
hell out of here and uh
it was a hot dz we had 70 or 80 90 uh vc
we hadn't realized that of course uh but
we had all these guys uh uh in the uh in
the uh and the jungle on the other side
of the uh the rice dike
and uh constant fire uh the uh you know
heroes you know carl providing that fire
at 70 80 100 feet above above ground
level he's uh he's right there in the in
the in the action
uh
that's that's not a hard shot to make if
you know how to shoot at elos uh thank
god they didn't uh
so
carl and his crew are in danger uh and
and uh then the uh then the slick uh the
helo is called the slick is because it
doesn't have the miniguns and the
rockets and so on slick comes in naked
to uh to pull us out of a uh out of a of
a hot lz
uh as you said uh he he hovered there
and i had to make those three trips
under fire uh and uh without uh wendell
hedge and gary lawrence providing that
cover fire i couldn't have gone back and
forth to that rice dike to get those
guys uh you know and so uh as uh
i'll i'll never forget it uh gary
lawrence is you know you know banging
away and
he uh he runs out of bullets
and uh and he calmly turns to me and he
says
i'm out of bullets
you know jesus h christ uh so seeing as
my as my weapon didn't work and i
usually went out with uh you know
a thousand to 1200 rounds of ammo on my
body
uh i uh i ripped
i ripped off a bandolier and and you
know for a little bit of background is
you know just like you see in those old
movies with pancho villa and all those
you know bad guys in the in the westerns
i got these bandoliers of ammo wrapped
around their body well that's exactly
what i had
but what i did is i put on a put on a
t-shirt or a blue and gold
wrapped the bandoliers around my body
and then on top of those i put on a on a
set of camis
not only to cut down on the uh on the
noise but it also cut down on the
reflection of the uh the brass of the
rounds and it protected them from
anything that we might run into
uh so when uh when those guys ran out of
bullets i did a button on my uh on my
cami uh you know shirt top and just
popped the uh pop the link and you know
threw 120 rounds off to lawrence and 120
and it's kind of like if you if you
watch it it's kind of like a snake
flying through the air and they grabbed
it and they uh they pop it down and they
uh you know slam it in the
in the receiver of their of their
weapons and they start returning fire
uh quite uh
quite a brave situation for those guys
and and they were completely exposed
yeah well we're all completely exposed
and as as i'm loading the uh the guys
into the helo uh i'd i'd like to take
full credit for that but uh the uh the
crew members as i got these guys up out
of the muck i mean you know the uh
because they hadn't set down into the
rice paddy the uh the deck of the uh of
the cabinet of the uh the huey was too
high for me to lift these guys and i'd
not get them up high enough and then the
crew members had you know dragged him
into the uh dragon of the hilo
uh so
it was a uh it was a bad day at
blackrock a real shitty day at blackrock
to be honest with you so was the worst
day of my career and the best
um i got a bunch of questions we'll
we'll get to vietnam uh back to vietnam
because i'd like to hear about how that
you know what your workup was like how
you ended up there we'll get there but
just to give us a little background on
you
let's just talk about you know what what
your childhood was like how did you
become the hulk
well that was pretty tough becoming a
hulk i'll tell you and i'll tell you why
my
my dad was a policeman
and today policemen who are our first
responders going out and dealing with uh
god knows what in society
they're not paid well enough for what
they do uh go back 60 or 70 years they
weren't paid you know period
so uh there weren't a lot of second
helpings at the the dinner table uh so
uh uh
while i grew to about uh you know about
six foot five eleven and a half is
probably the god's honest truth uh
if if it wasn't nailed down anybody else
in the house wasn't eating it i was
you know there's an old story about the
only thing that ever broke was a handle
on the refrigerator door well i i broke
the handle on the refrigerator door more
than once
uh
but somewhere
uh in uh i i
never wrestled i went to a uh
a catholic grammar school
and uh i am a retired catholic uh but i
went to a catholic grammar school and uh
got to uh to high school was the first
time i saw anything like uh like
wrestling and and it was interesting so
i went out for the wrestling team and uh
we had a uh a great uh freshman
wrestling coach
and uh i want to say his name was gordon
howe's wrath but uh
great a great coach and uh
he was
kind of ambivalent on the benefits of of
weight training
but he also was helpful in getting me a
a a lifeguard
job in a
village of bright waters in one of the
other beaches uh and uh that was on a
bay and a canal so
you didn't need any open water skills at
that point in time so uh what i did
that summer
is i had probably like a 110 or 150
pound weight set and i brought it over
to the uh to the beach and we had a
little you know garage kind of thing and
and on my breaks you know i'd go over do
a few sets this that or the other thing
uh lunch break i'd do a few more sets
and before i got on my bicycle and rode
home i'd do a few more sets
uh i came back to uh to wrestling the
the next year uh jv
and uh coach uh housewrath calls me out
to uh to use me as the demonstration
dummy on some particular move that he
was gonna do right
so uh he you know calls me out and i lay
down on the mat and he uh he you know
telling the rest of the team what he's
going to do and i just
locked
and here's this you know
35 year old man you know 165 170 pounds
uh you know you know wrestling uh you
know champion in his uh in his own right
and here's this you know smart ass kid
who's been lifting weights all summer
long and he couldn't move me
and he and he said to me says what did
you do
and uh you know change people's minds
about weightlifting and conditioning for
wrestling at least at bayshare high
school uh where did you get where did
you get the idea were you looking at
like
uh
uh magazines i mean how did you figure
out even the idea of weightlifting
where'd you get the weight set from well
ray played if you're listening to this
uh it's your fault uh we had a uh we had
a guy on the uh
uh on the uh on the football team uh
name is ray plate uh and uh
saw him in a you know 50-year reunion a
few years ago and uh he's doing well but
ray had arms that looked like somebody's
legs and ray wasn't the biggest guy on
the team by any stretch of the
imagination but ray was our nose tackle
and nobody on the other teams pushed rey
around
and i said
that looks like it works let's give that
a try and so i did and i learned i
learned a lot
on my own but uh
i uh i went down to uh
i got the navy rotc scholarship as you
said to uh to villanova and uh
uh
that's a uh that's an academic
scholarship uh uh you've gotta pass a
physical but it's it's not like uh you
know going to buzz i mean you got a you
got to fog a mirror you got to you have
20 20 vision and uh and
and that kind of thing and so uh
i uh you know got the scholarship and i
went on down to villanova
and uh yeah i could have you know tried
to walk onto the football team they did
not have a wrestling team i could have
tried to walk onto the football team but
you know i said i don't know what this
academic stuff is really going to be
i've got this scholarship so
before i overload my uh myself let me
just uh you know not go out for football
and so uh
the football team at the time used the
same weight room as you know
the wannabes or the anybody else at the
at the school
so i you know i lifted uh you know with
the uh with a lot of the guys on the uh
the football team and uh
there were there were a couple of
monsters on the football team and
the uh the number one rated 119 198
pound power lifter not only collegiately
but nationally aau
uh was on the villanova football team uh
name was john zarenko uh you know
stronger than the law allowed uh but uh
with a name like zarenko his nickname
was dizzy uh but uh john
uh john could uh could quote only bench
press about
three and a quarter 335 and he was
always complaining now listen this is
198 pounder you know five foot eight uh
198 pounder played fullback uh and he's
benching 335 pounds you know i mean
that's something to write home about
but john could squat 600 and something
he could deadlift 700 and something if
somebody tried to tackle him around the
waist they were going to break their
shoulder
so i really got interested in uh in
enlisting at the time and uh
we had a we had 198 another 198 pounder
at the at the school and uh jim robucci
was uh was also ranked nationally and uh
he was the number two 198 college lifter
uh
jim was a little bit stronger in the
upper body and uh you know jim had uh at
198 pounds a 410 pound bench press
competition bench press
so uh we uh
uh you know we were always going neck
and neck and i left it at 2 42.
uh yes i did get up to 250 if my wife is
listening to this
but
i lifted at 242 and uh
i had uh you know i had uh you know a
good strong 415 bench press and my last
collegiate meet i went into i opened it
for went to 415 because jim's record was
410 so i had to break it by five pounds
yeah you gotta screw with to boys you
know so i i hit the 415 just to get the
school record and uh
back then equipment was not as uh
regulated if you will as it is today you
know you know the bench had to be it did
not have to be
x number of centimeters high x number
centimeters wide so this bench was just
a little bit wider
than we were used to benching with and
when i hit that 415 i came down and it
sort of my shoulder sort of tweaked but
i pushed it up anyway and i just said
you know uh yeah i've you know gotta you
know do uh do deadlifts here i don't
want to really screw up the shoulder uh
because my plan had been to set the uh
the the record and i'd done it in the
gym at 4 35 but uh i never hit it in in
competition hit it in the gym but not
the competition
uh so
uh that that whole weightlifting thing
became uh it just
well it's something that that i you know
i'm still trying to do
uh
so
fast forward to showing up at but no
wait a minute we got to go back then we
got to go back how did you hear about
the single teams
uh
reader's digest
if you can believe it
reader's digest magazine
was that was that in high school was
that while you were at villanova that
was when i got to villanova
as i said uh my father was a policeman
we didn't have a lot of money in the
house uh and uh
um i'll i'll wail on my uh older brother
and uh and an older sister uh if there
was any money to go to college they got
it i did not
so
it was it was explained to me if i was
going to college i was going to college
on a scholarship
so uh i actually had a part-time job
that i was i was planning on doing the
day of the rotc exam
and my father says you're taking this
test and what it was 20 or 25 bucks
doesn't sound like much today but in 19
who was that uh 60 uh 65 that was a lot
of money 64 65 so anyway
i i passed on you know 20 or 25 bucks
and went into that uh rotc test with a
little bit of a bad attitude but as soon
as i got in the room i said oh wait a
minute yeah you're not getting the 25
bucks you know that's that's that's
history you know let's let's take the
test uh so as you may know you have to
take the test then you have to pass the
physical and
the
rotc program tells you that they will
provide you with the scholarship you
then have to apply to the university and
get accepted so a completely different
process
so uh i did
my father being a practicing or a
convert to catholicism was uh
adam and he says there's you know there
were about 50 schools on the list then
that had rotc scholarships he says
you can go to these five or six those
were like you know holy cross uh you
know villanova notre dame
uh those were those were the schools
that i had to apply to uh i applied and
uh you know that the rest of that is
history uh
so
uh
it was a it was it was a great program
so i get to villanova
and uh
i uh
what was back up a little bit more to
you know staying in school i was i was a
good student in high school i was uh you
know i was the one that the rest of the
honor class kids couldn't figure out
what i was doing in the room
so
and in
new york they had a uh
still do probably a program uh called
the regents uh regents testing uh so at
the end of end of the year uh you would
uh
you would take a uh a statewide exam in
you know math chemistry physics whatever
it might be
and uh
i don't think i got 194 in any of those
so that's part of what helped my uh you
know my
uh transcript for uh review by villanova
look looked pretty good
and i had
scholarship offers to
the
state university of new york system and
uh
i was you know pretty much determined
that i was going to go to a place called
cortland state
uh cortland had a uh
an excellent uh you know pt program uh
you know for uh teaching and uh
they uh they also had a pretty good
wrestling team at the time
uh so i uh how good did you do in
wrestling in high school
uh
i i did better than uh better than it
shows and i i'll tell you my uh my uh my
uh complaint on that one
uh
i uh
in my in my senior year uh
i i
was wrestling this one kid and uh i want
to say it was from uh from west islip
but uh one of our big rivals and so on
anyway the uh the guy stood on me
uh from the uh
in wrestling you have a you know you
start to start the match both guys are
on your feet and then the second and
third rounds you know you start with one
guy in what's called the bottom position
and the other guy uh his arms around
around the wrestlers in the top position
one of the
most common moves is a stand from the
bottom and the guy on the bottom will
stand and
rip the guy's hands off of his waist
the guy was on top and you know get away
and get his one point for the uh for the
neutral position
well
i said
you know okay stand so what i did is as
a guy was standing i just uh went up
with him used his own uh his own
momentum lifted him off his feet
and swung his body so it was kind of
like perpendicular to mine so now what i
did is i
uh instead of throwing them to the mat i
just you know bent down to the mat i you
know bent my knees and as i said this
guy is you know perpendicular to me
being upright so he's parallel to the
mat
so now that he's sliding down my side my
knee would hit the mat he'd slide down
along the side of my body and hit the
mat
nobody knew that this guy had had a
couple of damn concussions during the
football season
so when he bounced off the mat
he bounced and laid there
uh
that was not my plan my plan was to
teach him not to stand on tom richards
uh and uh you know so he's he's laying
on the mat
you know nice and
terms other than oh [ __ ] and you know
what the hell is going on here you know
went through my mind
and uh
unfortunately i got quote branded as a
dirty wrestler as a result of that
and
right after that they rewrote the damn
new york high school wrestling rule book
that had said
the man in control's knee had to touch
the mat before the opponent
which is exactly what i did
to
the man on top must safely return the
opponent to the mat
now i suppose it's an all-girls sport
not sure you know yes that shows a
certain amount of uh you know
male chauvinism you're right
uh but uh anyway uh i get to the uh
i get to the county meet
and uh
uh i'm in the uh you know semifinals or
something like that
and this
guy a guy stands up and starts to get
away from me
and
i try to take him down
uh not in the matter that i just
discussed but just like a double leg
take down and i and i get him and i pick
him up
and he squirms away from me
i don't have control of him he squirms
away from me
next thing i hear
is a uh is a whistle
i get penalized one point because they
claimed that when this guy got away from
me
that i threw him down to the mat
and when he got away from me
i had managed to scramble around behind
him and get control so i should have had
two points for a takedown long story
short
the guy put on his track shoes after
that yeah and and the refs never called
him for stalling i chased him around the
mat yada yada yeah i'm whining but i can
say that they rewrote the new york state
high school wrestling book
uh it was a it was a real disappointment
but quite frankly uh had i and so he he
ended up like second or third in the
state that year and i'm just saying to
myself
you know
you should have been a track star not a
wrestler but anyhow
but all things considered uh you know i
went on uh
you know i went on to the to the rotc
scholarship and uh had i
had i gone to new york had i won new
york state i'd probably had any number
of uh a wrestling scholarship so you
wouldn't be talking to me today if that
had happened so yeah we're good here
so then you so you pick up a reader's
digest at some point you read an article
about the seal teams
or was it about udt
so
my father as i said you know didn't have
the money for uh for a scholar for uh
for high school or college tuition or
anything like that so was your dad a vet
from world war ii yes he was and what
did he do and he was a uh he was a uh a
gunnery instructor and uh uh he he
actually never never left the united
states uh but uh you know one of the
places he was stationed was
portsmouth new hampshire
and after i retired i ended up working
for a company in portsmouth new
hampshire right on the naval base where
he was he was assigned
but go back to the
rotc scholarship uh that's that was my
uh that was my ticket to college my
ticket into the navy so as i'm looking
around the navy i'm trying to figure out
what it is that i want to do
i've been a lifeguard for years and
years and i was in you know decent shape
i could swim
and uh so i i
i
maybe uh you know still had you know pt
boats uh you know they were using them
over there in vietnam and so on
and i said yeah it's small boat stuff
you know sounds like you know some fun
yeah because i'd cut grass in the summer
times and save money and i bought my own
uh you know 14 foot uh you know boat
with a uh 30 horsepower john cena you
know you know evinrude outboard motor
and so you know small boats were
something i said okay this is what i
want to do uh and uh then of course
the navy doesn't have much of an
emphasis on that and so i look around i
find this udt stuff
i say okay it's swimming you know
working in the working in the in the
ocean and i work with demolitions you
know that sounds pretty interesting uh
so i said you know i'll try for that
and then i find this uh this article
about the uh about the seals and i said
that really sounds interesting and i
think i'd really like to do that
so i couldn't find out much about it
uh but uh
while i was there at villanova i let the
the staff know that this is this is what
i wanted to do
uh and i made the made the application
for uh for buds and uh and got accepted
well in my junior year at villanova i
had uh changed majors so in my
between my junior and senior year which
would have been your first class cruise
as a midshipman
i ended up going to summer school and i
did not make my
make my first class cruise
so i'm getting ready to graduate my
senior year and graduation and
commissioning is held sort of
simultaneously at villanova
and uh
i uh
get called into the uh you know
exo's office there at the rotc unit and
he says i got some bad news for you tom
i said
you won't get commissioned here in the
in beginning of may with everybody else
because you've got to go on a uh go on
your first class cruise before you can
get commissioned
well yeah you're not going to believe
this
that's when
yeah that's when the guy who did so well
on his uh you know rotc test uh you know
got his i got his brain back together
and
that's the first time i learned the
power of the uh of the pen and
independent thinking of the navy
so i write this letter to bupers and say
hey
i'm going to be a frogman i'm going to
be a seal i don't need this first class
cruz
what an arrogant jackass i was
so
long story short the navy comes back and
says okay
you don't have to go into first class
cruise i get commissioned with everybody
and and i go out the buds
got to back up just a little bit here so
as i'm
you know understanding that there's a
certain amount of
swimming required and probably running
in other conditioning you know i've i've
just gone out and you know bench pressed
you know 400 pounds at the uh at the the
collegiate uh you know weightlifting
champion and you're walking around at 2
45. i was walking around at 245 at that
point in time uh and uh you know squat
you know 500 and something on you know
dead lift uh you know five and a quarter
or something at that point in time long
story short several years later in the
career in my uh
once i was in the navy uh you know 10 10
years later in the navy 25 pounds
lighter 30 pounds lighter i lifted more
except for the bench press than i was at
villanova but anyway
uh so
uh
nobody in the rotc staff could tell me
what i needed to do
you know when i showed up in coronado
uh
and
so i said well
udt underwater you know got to be some
swimming here so yeah i jumped in the
pool with villanova about three times
maybe four
and i said well uh if there's gonna be a
lot of running involved you know you
know i started doing a little bit of
road work and i had i dropped 10 or 12
pounds and i showed up at coronado
thinking i was ready to go all right
so i show up they give me my first uh
issue of equipment and they tell me that
the uh the class that was in
pre-training at the time
is uh is over uh here at the at the
oceanfront go over there and tell them
who you are and uh that you're joining
the class
well i showed up
and uh
uh
walk up and the instructors look at me
like who the hell are you
and uh
before they even let me take a step they
make me go get a freaking ekg because
they thought that i was some short fat
you know pile of whatever and so
here here's another time when uh when
your
your alligator mouth overloads your
hummingbird ass
so uh we got instructors i don't i don't
remember if terry moy was there he's a
legend in our time and a legend in his
own mind uh but terry was uh was quite
the guy but there's another guy standing
there uh your complexion echo
and uh
he's uh his name is dick allen dick is
about 511. he's the all-navy and i think
he might have been the inner service
boxing champ
and dick was standing there at about 2
15 220
and i you know looked at chief allen and
i said you know [ __ ] he can do it i can
do it
oh my god
had to be one of the dumbest things that
i ever said in public to anybody so uh
they they kicked the [ __ ] out of me i
did not pass my first screen test uh
because like i said i didn't even know
what the screen test was
so they rolled me back to uh from class
53 to class 54 i didn't even you know
sign up with them
but uh
what year was this uh this was 1969. so
vietnam's in full swing full swing you
know you're going to vietnam if you go
to a single team absolutely and remember
there were only two seal teams at the
time
and i guess you
guys were still getting orders to udt
out of buds too at that time the
majority guys coming out of bud's got i
got orders to uh to to udt uh
was there was there any
i mean was the culture in america just
so split that
you just didn't even think about like
the hippies that are running around and
protesting wars did you did you see any
other were those people around villanova
were those people in coronado
so in my last semester at coronado
excuse me last semester at villanova
uh all these you know young uh
politically active individuals decided
that they had to make a statement
uh so they're holding a uh a rally and
they're blockading uh access to uh to
the campus
and you know [ __ ] i'm one of these guys
right you know well no i didn't i didn't
have the bank accounts i didn't i didn't
go to puerto rico or the virgin islands
on spring break uh but i'm one of these
guys they know who i am because i was
you know my senior year i was a bouncer
at a couple of bars that everybody went
to
so
here they are they're having this big
demonstration and uh i forget what
particular class it was over barkley
hall that i had but i'm walking over to
barkley hall and you've got this you
know you know mass of students and head
camp is closed you can't go you can't go
on campus now i say well
we we have one minor problem here
i've got a class in barclay hall right
over there
and i'm going to barkley hall and
the only problem is that you're
temporarily between me and barkley hall
so what's it going to be
they stepped aside and i went to class
it was easy
so so you had no idea what was going to
happen at buds
i had
no clue not a clue see i cleaned that up
pretty good
uh i had
i had i had
no i no idea what it was gonna be about
but uh while i was uh while i was at
villanova not only did i left at the gym
on base but there was a ymca in town
and i ran into this guy who claimed to
be a uh a retired you know navy corpsman
who would serve with the seals
uh
i can't remember his name you know 165
pound uh dark complected guy i think he
was italian american whatever
and uh
we we got to talking and he told me a
little bit about you know uh you know
the war stories and and and how tough it
was
but one of the things that he said to me
is he said
every one of those instructors
is a humanoid
every one of those instructors had done
whatever it is they're about to
ask you to do or what they're about to
do to you
so i said to myself i locked in my mind
at that point in time i said if that
human being or that human being
or even that marine over there can do
that
i can do that so that was the mindset i
went into buds with if he can do it i
can do it
and uh
it worked what was that what was was
there anything that was hard for you
did you suck it running or did you get
good at it pretty quick uh i i sucked at
running till graduation day
uh
but
uh you know uh you know with a you know
500 and you know some odd pound squat
you know going into uh going and
training uh i could i could i could run
uh i could i could do 50 or 100 yards
quick yeah
so when we
back when i went through training jocko
you remember when it was hard
uh we uh we we trained on the other side
uh uh
back where the ball feels our foreman
field is yeah so we'd finish up uh our
our pt on one side of foreman field uh
the side away from the bay towards the
ocean and over on the on the base side
of former foreman field uh was a uh a
row of uh pull-up bars and dip bars
so after pt uh we would go run over to
those bars and do pull-ups and dips
well the deal was the instructors would
break you into groups of x amount of
guys and you would run over to the to
the pull-up bars
the first guy in each group
got to stand there and you know scratch
his ass while everybody else is in the
lean and rest punching out 20 50 or
however many push-ups
i never did push-ups
after pt i was always the first man in
my running group to get over there
if it was over a hundred yards i was the
last man
but i never had to do push-ups in that
group but uh
so uh i don't know if we still call them
goon squads thing when you went through
uh okay i'm sure jocko i'm sure you made
a few of those i made some goon squads
you probably made all of them
the deal was and i didn't realize that
the deal was with the instructor staff
is that wherever instant richards is
that's where we cut the goon squad
so one day uh
you you know of admiral ray smith he was
in his class 54 and 54 is a class i
started with went through third phase
before i got a cellulitis infection so
yeah i'm a man of two countries or two
classes uh but i graduated with 55 but
anyway uh first phase ray and i were you
know
we're on one of the conditioning runs
and we're
running on north towards the north
island fence and we're uh we're just
about in front of the uh the lifeguard
towers at center beach there in coronado
and ray and i were running along just
having a conversation you know how i
mean because these conditioning runs
weren't fast uh they were you know hard
enough but they weren't real fast so ray
and i are running along having this
conversation and ray looks around and he
realizes oh [ __ ] we're we're right about
here at the
point where they're gonna cut the goon
squads he said tom i got to go
and ray literally took off at that point
in time and he was no more than 10 or 15
yards in front of me where the
instructor steps in and says all right
everybody
assume the position that is push-ups
because we're starting the goon squat
boom and so they cut the goon squad
wherever i was
except one time
so we're doing a soft sand conditioning
run this time we're going
south and uh
we're running down towards the uh
towards the uh the public beach down
there and that's about a a three mile
point but uh right across from the uh
uh
where the marina is there used to be a
great big pile of sand
and we call that mount suribachi
well the uh the instructors uh would
take us down the soft sand road uh which
was between the uh the ocean front and
just probably got you know 30 or 40
yards in from the strand highway
we'd run down that soft sand road
and uh then we'd get them out suribachi
and we'd run around mount suribachi we
brought up but over mounts are watching
well
i got tired of all this running up and
down mount suribachi stuff you know what
i'm saying
i mean
i've i've tossed my cookies you know
more times than i can tell you and uh
and i am one hurting son of a gun
so
they you know they go up and over mount
suribachi they loop around and they head
on down towards the uh towards the state
park beach there
and i don't even have the freaking class
in sight
right you know today today an instructor
gets shot for losing track of
of a student but they i don't even have
a class in sight so the class goes down
and i know with i know what the run is
for the day so they're going to come
back so i just you know loop around
suribachi real nice and easy this time
loop around suribachi the class comes
back i loop around in the back of the
class and and it just worked out the
instructors were looking forward as i
came up and the goon squad had already
been cut down by the state
state park
i'm i i as i had caught up to the class
uh this uh
great big
instructor uh by the name of tracks bear
trax uh williams uh
looks over the class and he sees me as
the last man in the formation
and he looks at me
and he says
ensign richards
i don't know
how you got to be here
i do know you're not supposed to be here
but somehow you did it so i'm gonna let
you stay here and that is the only goon
squad i ever missed
uh how many so i guess you said you were
in 54. that's who you went through hell
week with right i went i went through uh
hell week and diving phase was the third
phase at that point in time so i went
already all the way all the way into the
second phase of the diving week before i
got a cellulitis infection that actually
hospitalized me
how many people quit during her week
we started with slightly over
uh slightly over 200 guys in class 54
and we ended up with uh right around
52 54 guys uh you know graduating out of
54 so we lost 150 guys
just ringing out
ringing that bell
kind of crazy
and then
you said at this time some guys would
get orders to udt some guys would get
orders to seal team
it seemed like at one point it was you
were gonna go to udt most likely
yeah a couple guys would go to seal team
and you ended up getting orders to seal
team yes uh and as far as i'm concerned
that was no accident because what i did
is uh i realized that the situation is
just as few expressed uh and that only a
few guys ended up going to the seal
teams well uh
i uh petitioned a couple of the uh of
the instructors uh that uh hey
i really want to go to seal team uh and
uh you know one of them was a uh
uh a highly decorated uh
uh seal chief by the name of uh you know
tommy hatchet i don't know if that name
rings a bell to you uh but uh
tom was uh was one of the few black guys
we had in the teams at the time
and i went up to uh to chief hatchet and
i said you know chief uh
i really want to go to go to seal team
one i said i think that's where i belong
and i i went up to a couple of other
league instructors and now at this point
in time the chief hatchet was uh
uh chief hatchet was in the second phase
and i'm in third phase but you know i
went to those guys because uh second
phase of course not of course second
phase was
land warfare and those are the uh the
the seal guys and i said you know yeah
this is this is what i want to do and uh
obviously they must have said something
to somebody uh because uh because they
let me go
so you show up to seal team one let's go
let's back up i want to tell i want to
tell two training stories here hundred
percent uh
in uh
different different hell weeks have uh
have different uh layouts you know
what's done when uh because of course
the uh the the students you know learn
too much about what's coming up uh next
and then they can sort of you know get
their minds uh get their minds around it
so
uh when uh
admiral smith and i went through
training together uh one of the events
that they did was uh you know i don't
know what they called it but let's call
it the last man standing
that is they drew a circle in the sand
put the class inside the circle and said
that the last guy inside the circle gets
x number of points for his uh first boat
team
well uh you know ray smith was a i was a
boxing champion at the at the naval
academy uh
she says i want to say uh
uh he he was a uh he was a weight man
that is he threw uh uh through the uh
the hammer or something like that
uh so ray was a pretty pretty strong guy
ray was about 200 pounds maybe 205 at
the most maybe a buck 95.
so he was taller too right yeah about my
height oh really might have been just a
little bit taller oh i mean because
he did look kind of skinny
so uh
ray and i went up to each other and we
said hey let's
let's make this easy on ourselves we'll
throw everybody else out of the circle
and it'll be you and i and see who gets
the points of the book group that's
exactly what we did we threw those other
50 suckers out of the
end of the circle and uh
came down to ray and i wrestling on the
ground and i'm trying to you know pick
them up and throw them out of the circle
when uh you know instructor moy sees
that i've i've raised my head to you
know see where the line is and where
i've got uh where i've got ray so i can
toss them out of there
and just as i raised my head instructor
moy had a ibs paddle full of sand and
threw it in my face
you know basically i had eyes ears nose
and mouth full of sand and
quite frankly i thought i was blinded uh
but uh
the uh
the students say that
after i
roared at instructor moy that i only
missed them by a couple of steps
because i i said screw screw it screw it
lieutenant jg smith i'm going after that
son of a [ __ ] you just filled my face
full of sand uh
i missed i missed the instructor uh and
they had one of the guys take me down
the water and
clear me out and i you know
the crappy thing is that ray smith
didn't even get the points for his boat
crew uh because uh he didn't throw me
out i i left them my own accord
so fast forward 20 some odd years
i'm now the uh the skipper of uh of buds
and uh
uh ray is uh is the admiral in charge of
uh naval special warfare command
and uh ray and his wife kathy are living
across the street on the mfib base
and uh
ray's son is going through seal training
so uh
ray uh you know we have we have the
breakout and uh you know some people the
breakout includes uh
busting the students out of the barracks
giving them all sorts of confusing
directions and things to do
there's also instructors firing blanks
from m60 machine guns
using you know flash bangs which are a
very bright very loud
explosive simulator to disorient the
students
and yet here you know a couple hundred
yards away on the other side of the
strand highway is navy housing
so
usually that sunday night when we
started hell week we the phones lit up
and
uh one night it was
admiral smith's wife kathy complaining
to ray you know
what is tom doing to those boys
so as their son goes through training
uh
i was you know particularly careful to
make sure that
that i did not single uh you know him
out but uh i was it was also uh you know
attentive to the fact that you know
sometimes uh the son of a we call them
legacies going through training uh just
like they did and what was that uh was
that movie uh
uh animal house uh you know legacies uh
but uh we we wanted to make sure that uh
you know if somebody's father had been
jackass of the week to one of the uh the
instructors that that that didn't carry
over and taint his uh son's attempt to
get through training
but anyway i remember a member ray
coming you know telling me the story
about
ray do you realize what they're doing to
these boys
i'm sorry kathy if you hear this but uh
ray was ray was concerned about or kathy
was concerned about her son
ray and kathy were married when when ray
and i went through training but you know
ray obviously did a phenomenal job of
not you know telling kathy about what
how bad his day was yeah that's a hard
thing to camouflage too because you're
coming home with you chafing you're
bruised up and beat up you've got cuts
and nicks all over your body and sweat
your ankles and knees are swelled up
it's pretty savage
absolutely but
you know kathy obviously didn't
appreciate what ray was going through
when he went through training
so we get through
nate's
first phase he makes it that makes it
through hell week
and well not quite
so
when ray and i went through training
hell week secured on saturday morning
not that you had it easy jocko i
understand
training training secured on saturday
morning well uh when i was the uh the
skipper of the center uh training
secured on friday morning
you got a whole 24 hours off so uh
the uh as i mentioned earlier uh you
know guys learn you know tricks about
what happens at what point in time
during hell week
and so
the classes had come to understand that
okay around 10 10 30 maybe 11 o'clock on
friday they're gonna secure you you know
because the corpsman got to give you a
check and then you know they gotta you
gotta make sure that we get anybody over
to balboa who needs to go to balboa
that's balboa naval hospital uh but uh
yeah of course the instructors want to
get off by uh by three or four o'clock
in the afternoon so gotta secure
everybody early enough so the students
knew this
so the students uh you know so i i i get
the instructor staff together and say
this is what we're going to do
the students
think that at the end of this particular
evolution
their week is over so when they get when
you get them lined up here they're
thinking we're done
so
we're not done
so what i did is i went out to you know
they thought i was coming over the uh
coming over the dune to these guys lined
up by the uh by the ocean that i was
going to secure training
secure hell week secure means to finish
it up close it down
so i come over the uh come over the uh
the berm
and i walk down to the class and i start
to engage ensign smith in conversation
along the lines of you know instant
smith you you probably remember stories
of your father that he and i went
through uh through buds together and
everybody is a soup sandwich at the end
of hell week whether it's friday morning
whether it's friday morning or saturday
morning everybody's a soup sandwich
ensign smith was no better and he has no
idea what the hell i'm talking about
he just knows that they're standing
there getting ready to get secured
so i said
and since smith do you recall that uh
when your dad and i went through seal
training uh
the seal training didn't secure until
saturday morning
this is only this is only you know 10 30
friday morning i guess you guys got
another 24 hours and i turned around and
i left
i did not secure whole week we got all
these kids thinking
we're done we've made it
maybe i can get a hot shower
i can't take another step if i had to
and there's guys with tears running down
their faces
uh and they turned and turned to each
other i i can't do it
i can't i can't make another 24 hours
so the deal i had with the instructor
staff was okay they you know you know
muster the kids up and you know off they
go on a uh on a on an ibs carry towards
the uh towards the rocks in front of the
hotel dell
and
uh
what i wanted him to do was to suck it
up
and do whatever was necessary
and so
these kids sucked it up and they went
down to the uh to the hotel dell and
came back and i secured him and when i
secured him
i said
this is a lesson you're probably never
going to forget in your life
you thought that this was going to
happen that is hell week was going to be
secured an hour ago
it didn't happen you needed to suck it
up and figure out what to do
at that point in time and maybe it still
goes on today but classes uh would have
a t-shirt made for for their class and
there'd be some kind of a cartoon or
caricature on it and a uh and a saying
well that class is saying was
it isn't over
till it's over
and every one of them every one of them
learned a lesson not only in that class
but for the next several classes they
didn't know what was going to happen
that was my objective
keep them confused keep them confused
something else i did when i was a ceo of
buds
was
establish something called the junior
officer training course now as we all
know today uh seal training is broken
into
several sections but two distinct
sections the first approximate six
months is equal to what i did back when
i went through training the second
six months
where you earn your qualification as a
seal
is more advanced training
in in my day
[Music]
they had something called seal basic
indoctrination training that is you
would get to the seal team you would go
through this
five or six weeks of advanced training
which is what today's second six months
is
uh
you would go through that next
six weeks or so of advanced training and
the decision would be made whether or
not the commanding officer is going to
recommend you for your trident or you to
become a seal
when i graduated from seal training
me and x number of guys as we discussed
a few moments ago went directly to seal
team one a bunch of guys went to udt's
11 and 12.
uh 13 was still around then too
so uh
what happened was those friendships that
you and believe me
as you know jacqueline i'm sure you guys
understand there are no tighter
associations of friendships than you
form when you go through buds training
so what would happen
was
naturally when you get a bunch of guys
10 or 15 guys from a particular class
going to a particular team they tend to
hang out together to include the junior
officers and
the uh you know
uh
naval special warfare is probably one of
the few organizations where there are a
lot of close friends between the
officers and the enlisted and i mean
really close friends first name basis
you name it uh you know grand you know
godparents to kids you name it um close
association
what i wanted to do was i wanted to
break that
bond i wanted to break that dependency
i wanted those junior officers to have
to go to a team and stand on their own
not be able to lean on a bunch of guys
that they had gone through training with
they were now
officers they were now going to have to
make some significant decisions that
would potentially affect some of their
fellow classmates they were always
officers if you will and you know going
through training that officers were
assigned
more responsibilities and leaned on
harder than the uh than some of the
troops but i wanted to give these guys
not only separation
but i want to give them some tools to
work with so
i started at that point in time what i
call the junior officer training class
uh and it was only
two and a half or three weeks at the at
the outset i don't know what it is today
uh but we set that set that program up
for for two reasons leadership training
uh you know uh
management uh you know uh you know
training uh exposure to uh to other
other factors about the navy other than
buds training
so uh i i i set that up and and now that
junior officer training is is part of
that uh second six months of uh of of
the of the buds training uh but uh
i feel
i feel proud the fact that that still
exists and and and of course it's part
of that
evolution of training that is naturally
going to happen but uh it was one of the
one of the best things that i thought
that i did uh while i was the ceo of
butts yeah and just it's expanded a ton
i know my buddy leif was actually when
we got home from our last deployment
together he took over
the that jotsy course expanded we
started he started taking guys out in
the field we really focused on
leadership and i think it by by the time
he was done i think it was out to maybe
six weeks
and just trying to make it more more
comprehensive and get the guys more
prepared for when they do show up at a
seal team yeah so yeah it's still there
yeah we put together a uh a reading list
uh you know and uh we
uh
not just so that uh guys that have a
list to refer to we we made everybody
take a book and provide a a summary
i forget the name of the uh the young
ensign who
took uh dick marcinko's first book uh
rogue warrior and before i say anything
else
sorry to see that dick has passed uh he
was a uh
a very influential individual in the
development of uh
development group seal team six whatever
whatever they're called today uh
although you know dick did things his
own way
ruffled a few feathers in the process
i have nothing but the greatest personal
respect for dick marcinko
so dick gets out of the navy after a
some kind of a felony conviction uh
tom richards personally feels it yeah i
don't think
i don't think dick marcinko would do
anything like you know
of a felony nature just that's just not
who dick was dick could be a royal pain
in the ass and uh you know you you name
it but uh uh you know dick dick got some
things done so anyway he writes this
book rogue warrior uh
first of his books and uh
in it he reveals a number of things that
were probably uh you know you know
classified at the time and but he he
just uh you know served some time and i
think i think he retired as a commander
i'm not sure what uh what happened to
him he had been promoted to captain but
in any event
uh
the the navy decided not to
uh
slap his wrist about some of the things
that were in the book
but you could tell reading the book
that
dick had not separated from the navy on
the greatest of terms
and so
this young junior officer who was the
first guy to review dick's book
titles his book review
rogue winer
as opposed to road warrior
uh i'll i'll i'll never forget that uh
that that incident and
he had he he noted some of the things
that uh dick said and he saw some of the
uh the way that dick was uh
you know
poking his finger back in the eye of the
united states navy kid did a very good
uh very good job and of course that's
exactly what dick was doing saying [ __ ]
you the united states navy because uh
you know dick uh well that's who dick
was
that was a junior officer training
course was a uh was something that i was
really proud of
so you obviously at the end of buds for
you you didn't have junior officer
training course you just showed up to
the seal team and that's why that's why
i created that junior roster training
course because i i saw what i was
missing i mean i walk into a team and
now i've got to uh you know how many
years have you had uh before you got
commissioned jocko i had eight eight
years here i go
you know what behind the years uh yeah
ensign and i'm walking in and i've got
to be
the guy in charge of guys like jocko
who's got eight years under his belt or
uh in in my seal platoon we had uh uh
jack schultz
and uh who was the uh randy sheridan two
uh two first class i think jack made
chief during that period of time you
know
i really should have been in a learning
mode as opposed to a leading mode at
that point in time and i learned as much
as i could from those guys
uh
so again that that goes back to uh the
whole uh whole premise of that jotc so
so you graduate from buds now
it's just checking into seal team how
many guys from your class went to seal
team one
i don't remember uh you know uh gary
stubblefield uh you know best man of my
wedding and so on uh and uh he and i
deployed to vietnam surely right there
after was it right 1970 when you
graduated right i graduated in april of
april of 1970 uh uh that was 55 class 54
graduated in february
uh and uh
uh gary was from 54. uh
there were there were half a dozen of us
maybe um no more than a dozen now that
went to uh to team one
and uh
you know right into uh right into
platoons
right into pre-deployment training and
boom gone
i know i talked to some of the guys from
vietnam and they said when they checked
into team one i remember one guy telling
me like you got in the shower you know
after a pt or something he's looking at
every everybody's like shot up
everybody's wounded it's just uh so much
combat for those guys back in that time
and the seal team
seal team won until team two that's the
for the seal teams and there's what you
have 150 guys at the team
thereabouts
that's a that's a good number
and
we had uh we had situations in uh at
seal team one where a platoon uh uh
would be uh you know scheduled to uh uh
you know come back from a uh from a
deployment and the deploying platoon is
headed on over there and uh and maybe
they they hook up in the philippines
where a couple of guys from that platoon
that was supposedly coming back to the
states a couple of those guys would
augment that platoon and go right go
right back in country uh there were
there were a lot of uh there were a lot
of deployments like that and uh and a
lot of a lot of hard men
how long did it take for you to get your
training so you went through sbi and sbi
you said was like eight weeks long uh
about uh probably closer to six
uh and uh and that must have just been
straight just jungle training uh jungle
training uh you remember an island out
there in california and the salton sea
and the uh the uh
uh
irrigation uh canals and so on that feed
into that provided some really uh you
know interesting terrain and of course
it's the freaking desert so it's hot
uh so it was uh it was it was a really
good place to train and then you and
then at the end of
sbi
that's when you get your trident right
and then you get put into a platoon
absolutely and at that point in time you
were going into a platoon
and the uh the challenge for the co and
xo at the time of course is okay what's
the the makeup of the platoon now we uh
normally want to have a uh an officer
making a second deployment uh and uh
then you've got uh
a couple of a couple of senior enlisted
uh and maybe a couple of junior enlisted
senior enlisted might be on their third
trip the junior guys might be on their
on their second
but we had a uh
we had a a green platoon uh
grant telfer was a uh a surface warfare
officer before he went through training
and he started training as a lieutenant
so and i don't remember how many uh you
know how many
years senior to me he was
but he started training as a lieutenant
uh and uh
uh
was that his first platoon as well
exactly uh he he he and i graduated in
class 55 oh okay so uh
the
exo called me in and you know asked if
uh
asked if i uh wanted to be uh the uh
aoic and in grand splatoon
and i said sure uh yeah
that that gets me uh get it gets me
where i wanna go sooner than it normally
would have so you bet and as i said we
had jack schultz who later got
commissioned
retired as a commander out of uh had a
dev group
and randy sheridan who
got wounded and i think he was medically
retired uh
uh from uh from uh you know an action in
uh
uh in vietnam with uh with the platoon
uh
randall hedge
uh and i think moses marquez were the
other two guys who had prior uh
prior deployments so we out of out of 14
guys uh
10 of us were fngs
so you do a workup
and you're preparing to go now you're
together with your platoon and how long
is that do you spend six months like
nowadays we do oh
no uh in in that case as i said so i got
i got there in april we deployed in the
end of august i got there in april and
went through sbi yeah doing the math
yeah i i go through sbi and finish up
sbi and they're putting together this
platoon zulu platoon
and uh then we we get zulu platoon put
together we go right into uh right into
pre-deployment training so uh and it was
only x number of weeks uh in a couple of
months uh because we had to finish up uh
you know with enough time to give give
guys a a weaker days off before uh
deploying just to you know take care of
business uh so it was it was a pretty uh
you know slam bam situation but you had
the the awesome thing is you had guys
coming back from vietnam that were
running your training for your platoon
oh absolutely uh
the
sbi program uh when i went through it
was uh run by uh guys like uh
uh master chief al hui uh and uh you
know uncle al uh master chief alu he was
i was a fantastic individual
i don't think i ever heard him raise his
voice
and i don't think i ever saw anybody
working for him not to exactly what the
hell they were told to do
uh
he was he was a piece of work i remember
i remember working without later in life
it was just uh just a pleasure but uh
al uh
gary gallagher
uh you know gary i just know these names
okay gary gallagher nicknamed muncher
navy judo champion
he's one of the instructors so we set up
this uh this event where we're supposed
to
uh take down a hooch we're supposed to
enter it search it and uh if there's
anybody in there you know take him
hostage and uh you know search for
whatever might be there
so we go to the uh we go to the hooch
and uh
we we set up
i'm i'm on the outside of the door and
i'm i'm facing away from the hooch just
as security just in case somebody comes
up while the guys are inside
well the bad guy in there is muncher
muncher is 200 pounds
like i say all navy judo champion right
muncher throws a couple of guys away in
the in the inside of the inside of the
hooch he comes blasting out the door
the hulk is on his knees you know you
know there to uh to provide security i
got my my my weapon uh you know at the
ready and
as al huey
ripped on uh
chief gallagher
you let that
220 pound incident who's on his knees
catch you and wrap you up
because i mean i caught him from behind
i caught gallagher from behind and just
wrapped them up in a nice neat package
and uh master gpu he had a uh had a
blast with that but uh yeah but lesson
learned you know there there we go
here's this uh here's this bleeder
coming out and uh you know you got to be
prepared for uh for those uh for those
bleeders coming out and you guys were re
there was no other mission that you were
looking to do other you know you're
going in vietnam and that's just 100 of
the focus
complete uh i mean when you look at the
the mission focus that the the seal
platoons have today uh the breadth of uh
the breadth of the the type of missions
they can get you know like interdiction
at sea taking down a ship at sea
i never thought of that you know i mean
uh i wouldn't have had a clue of how to
do it yeah i'm sure uh as our guys have
done today we've clearly figured out how
to do that uh and and those type of
things no you know we uh we were we were
focused on one thing we were created by
president kennedy to do that
and did you always carry a stoner
right that was my that was my weapon in
the field
and even when you were telling that
story you you were throwing linked 556
ammo to two other guys right so how many
stoners did you have in that squad
uh let me see where gary and gary and
wendell might have been the only other
uh because i think uh yeah i think gary
and wendell were probably the only other
two guys the rest of the guys had
m16 or m16 variants but the important
part of that is and one of the reasons
why uh multiple guys were carrying
stoners is so that you had that
ammunition interoperability and you know
my uh the receiver group of my weapon
took four rounds uh and the guy said if
if that stoner hadn't been across my
chest where it was i'd have been i'd had
four holes i i wouldn't be i wouldn't be
here having that conversation today so
my gun was an inoperable model uh but as
i said i carried anywhere from a
thousand twelve hundred rounds on on an
op and uh i had i had plenty to give
away when you so when you guys so you
guys get done with deployment and now
you're going you're flying over to
vietnam do you guys fly commercial over
to vietnam how'd you get over there
fly commercial no yes
all kinds of sock guys flew over there a
lot of army replacements they flew over
their commercial air or i guess it was
chartered flights that's what it was so
the regular army guys which fly over
there
in commercial flights we we flew over
and i believe what might have been the
last united states navy c-118 i believe
it was
and uh you know we were going to go to
hawaii from hawaii to the pi and then to
uh and then to uh you know tonsille
airport and uh in saigon
so
as
navy pilots would have the habit of
doing
ah shucks we got the hawaiian
broke down for a few days
well uh
uh
none of us
none of us were rich at the time uh or
now but uh
you know i had i had a few bucks and uh
you know managed to waste it uh but i
also uh you know was able to distribute
a few bucks to some of the other guys in
the platoon because we had no money we
didn't figure we were gonna be anywhere
we were gonna have to pay for anything
or have a chance to go buy a beer uh but
uh so we uh we broke down and uh broke
down in hawaii
and uh
that's where that's where grant telfer
showed us his uh his uh palm tree
climbing skills to go up and uh you know
pick a coconut
and then from there you go did you stop
in the pi um we did
and then from there you get into vietnam
what what's the what's what's it like
when you hit the ground in vietnam
hotter than i could have imagined we're
talking august in in vietnam and uh yeah
i i didn't grow up with uh with air
conditioning
but i grew up on long island and you had
the long island sound on one side and
you had the atlantic ocean on the other
side so it never got really got you know
particularly hot
uh so uh you know the uh
uh going through uh going through
training in the summer and coronado was
as hot as i've ever been
before i got to uh before i got to
vietnam
and uh it was just hot humid muggy
uh and uh
a uh a hyperkinetic level of activity
like
it's hard to describe
so what was your
where where were you located uh
we uh we spent a few days in saigon and
then we were shipped down to uh uh the
the very southern tip of vietnam
if you look at vietnam on a map there's
kind of like a little tail kind of like
the uh the keys in in florida well
there's a little tail down there and uh
the very bottom part of uh
of vietnam and we were on the uh we're
on something called the coulon river
down there and did you have another
platoon with you or is it just zulu
there were several platoons you know
cycling through there
what we had was something called uh sea
float and sea float was a series of
barges
lashed together in the in the river uh
with detachments of uh you know patrol
boats operating from there and seal
platoons operating from uh
from the uh from the barges
shortly after we got there and when we
arrived they had already started
building a uh a uh a short airstrip uh
and some uh what do they call them sea
huts uh you know uh you know
plywood and uh you know screen sides and
uh yeah you know didn't do much more
than uh block the rain of course there
was no no ac
and what was the mission set you guys
were given
we were we were there to uh to look for
uh for vc uh
vc tax collectors uh you know anybody
infiltrating that uh that part of the
world
gather the intelligence try to find out
who these folks were where they were and
go after them uh we did
we we did specific
ops going in for
an individual at a location uh we did
things like
going out in
sandpans patrolling at night looking for
the uh for the vc tax collectors uh
you're trying to hit up the uh the
locals uh we'd sit on uh sit on uh you
know riverside ambushes uh you know
looking for these guys uh
i missed a particular uh operation but
uh uh grant uh grant telfer's squad had
a uh had a phenomenal op uh you know
based on some intelligence that we
generated uh and again uh you know jack
schultz uh uh would uh would go off uh
you know uh checking with uh the prus
the uh the advisors and you know looking
for you know bits and pieces of
intelligence and one of the uh
one of the coups that they came up with
was a uh a weapons storage facility uh
not too far from uh from where solid
anchor was located down there in the uh
namcan province
at that point in time our squad was up
in a place called damdoyer you know
25 30 miles up the river or something
like that uh and operating out out of
there we thought uh you know it might be
some virgin territory we could uh go
find some bad guys but while we were up
there uh you know grant and uh the other
guys found this uh you know one of the
largest uh ammo caches uh you know vc
ammo caches
located in the in the war
yeah what was your op tempo like how
often were you guys going out i've heard
didn't they sometimes rotate squad one
tonight squad two tomorrow night and
then go back and forth absolutely uh and
sometimes if you if you didn't have
something to work with uh
it might be
every third day might be every fourth
day uh but uh
oh boy uh we had a uh
we had a a little uh sign hanging on the
uh
on the uh on the outside of the hooch
actually that uh that's that
you know where you draw the little lines
and then a slash through it you know
five uh those are the uh those were that
was a tally what we of the of the known
kias uh i i really don't remember the uh
the total number of ops that we did in
that uh in that six months
but it was a but it was a heavy op tempo
you were working a lot it it was it was
heavy enough yeah i i would not have
wanted to have to go out more often than
that uh you come back yeah because you
go out and you completely break your uh
circadian rhythms uh you know you you go
out and you go out at night and you're
you're exhausted you're slogging through
uh through your ankle knee deep uh you
know mud carrying you know 50 60 pounds
of of gear and if you uh you you patrol
you know
five ten uh clicks 15 clicks doing that
stuff you're a whipped puppy and it
takes a couple of days to respond
because you don't want to go out tired
and you don't want to go out not fresh
because if you do somebody's going to
die
so you had would you guys have did you
guys have 14 men in your platoon exactly
14 guys
the squads you're going out with was
seven
seven six five whatever whatever
whatever we felt was uh
necessary we uh we were sitting down
there at uh on the on solid anchor and
we were routinely getting mortared uh
you know from some place you know a few
clicks uh to the
east and a few clicks north
so uh what you do is you you look at the
at the impact of the mortar and you can
tell by the uh the size of the hole that
the mortar makes whether it's a uh
uh
51 or uh 82 millimeter mortar that's the
the bad guys did the 82. we had 81s
right okay thanks it's been a while uh
so you could tell by the size of the uh
of the crater
what what uh what size mortar it was and
that tells you the uh the maximum range
of the mortar and again again looking at
the crater you could also tell if it was
a uh it was a high angle shot coming
down from a short range or
and so you could you could kind of
figure out that range and then of course
the orientation of the of the crater
from the impact tells you the uh the
azimuth the back azimuth where it's
coming
so we kind of did that and we said okay
they're probably coming right down this
here river and setting up about here so
we went out early and set up further so
that they'd have to come down in front
of us
uh you know we were tired of having card
games interrupted by a motor attack you
know
so uh
we uh
quite frankly that's true there were
several motor attacks where we were out
of that out of that card game and into
the uh into the bomb shelter before the
freaking cards hitting the floor i'm
telling you uh
but so we went up there to uh to try to
intercept this uh this mortar crew
and uh of course you want to be careful
and not tip your hand with uh with any
kind of a uh vr visual reconnaissance of
the uh of the area so we
we did a vr and then we came and then we
set the opa a few a few days later
but the canopy was so hard what we
missed was another trail on the river
so we set up
x number of yards off the river so we'd
have a field of fire on the river
because we figured they're coming down
the river
oh no
these boys are coming down this
well-worn track behind us you know you
know whistling dixie or whatever the
vietnamese were uh we're doing there you
all of a sudden we're sitting here
facing the river
and we hear this chatter going on behind
us
as these guys are walking behind us with
the uh with the with the mortar
and
we couldn't
we couldn't do anything that is if we
started to make the noise to shift and
try to take them uh under fire we'd have
given uh these guys are walking down the
trail with their with their guns in
their hands you know we're sitting there
uh sitting there lying there kneeling
there uh you know in position facing the
river without guns pointing in the wrong
direction guns pointing in the wrong
direction so we'd uh we'd have made a
hell of a lot of racket and we we'd have
taken some hits
so we call off the mission and uh you
know later on we were uh
we're in our own sandpans paddling back
to uh
back to solid anchor
and you look off in the distance and you
see this flash
well the the vietnamese had a uh
millimeter battery across the river from
solid anchor
and uh we also had a uh a shared
talk a tactical operations center
and before we went out we put in a
designated no fire zone
so we're paddling our sand pans back
down
the uh the river
and i see these flashes
and because of the angle of the flash
you know it's headed in your freaking
direction
and you know i said well
and that could be anywhere near us
all of a sudden there's an air burst
almost directly above us
and then a few more air bursts you know
up and down the river where we are
i get on that radio and and i you know
to the u.s side of the talk
you know ceasefire
probably said a few things in on the air
that i shouldn't have said but cease
fire
they cease fire uh
and uh
and i got back to the talk and and and
i'm a jg
i had this [ __ ] lieutenant about uh
hanging from the rafters as i was
explaining to him you know how he almost
how he almost killed some of us i could
not believe you could see
you could see
the shrapnel
peppering the water
all around us nobody got hit
i don't know how that happened
another lucky day on the ranch
uh how often would you say you guys
would get an enemy contact when you guys
went out
i don't want
um
the kind of guy i am not enough uh yeah
we went over there killed bad guys you
know uh these people had caused the
united states of america to get into a
shooting war over here and so my job was
to kill the bad guys and we didn't uh we
didn't have enough contact as far as i'm
concerned
you know you know
i'll i'll finish up with another thought
on that but uh you know that's that's
that's what i signed up to do and if the
nation comes to a point where that needs
to be done
send me coach you know that's that's
that's
that's who is in the seal teams that's
why you have seal teams special forces
green berets air force special
operations guys these guys you know send
me coach that's what we're here for
so as you got towards because the the
event that we started off talking about
that was one of the last operations that
you guys were scheduled to do is that
right absolutely we had we had deployed
in in august of 70 and uh we were you
know scheduled to uh to come back the uh
beginning of february of 71
and uh and my squad had uh you know
started uh you know you know cleaning
the gear and preparing the gear to pack
it up and uh and send it home
because one of the last things you have
to do is is clean everything because
it's going to be inspected to make sure
you're not bringing back any particular
mud flora fauna or whatever from uh from
overseas so you gotta it takes a while
to prepare we'd started that process in
my squad and grant
grant wanted to do one more operation
and
since it was grant uh with whether
whatever information he had had i wasn't
paying attention to it uh
i was working with my guys getting ready
getting ready to come home
but his operation didn't quite go as he
planned because he flew they got
contacted in the helicopters
they they took fire on the way into the
area where they were going to go
and that's when uh marcus arroyo got
shot in the shoulder and wounded it
seriously enough to end up uh being
medically retired
so they they so squad one goes out to
execute this mission as they're flying
into this lz
they take fire
arroyo gets wounded it's bad enough that
they can't they have they have to abort
the mission
they come back to base
they come back to base and uh they take
marcus off the uh the plane our corpsman
uh doc harris tom harris
who's on his deathbed uh
tom harris takes uh
marcus down to
you know we had a
calling sick bay not much more than that
uh there at solid anchor and tom is
monitoring uh you know what's going on
with marcus
uh
doc harris was uh excuse me marcus was
uh
the radio man for that that squad uh doc
harris was the other radium in the other
radio men in the platoon
uh doc harris has taken care of marcus
arroyo and uh
so uh
grant needed a radioman and so uh
my basic thought is it's not smart to go
back
grant wanted to go back
uh
and i said well you're going back
somebody's gonna have to carry your ass
out of the rice paddy i'll carry the
radio uh
words to uh words to that effect
uh and uh
we uh you know it wasn't too you know to
to grant and i don't want to say in
defense but you know
in grant's thought process it wasn't
exactly where he was going in
uh but so anyway we go back to that area
and uh
we uh we took fire as we were coming in
and uh we uh uh we we landed and we went
up a rice patty over one and up the next
and uh
we were as i say taking fire almost
immediately but we went up that
uh third section of rice paddy uh we
were just uh we were just in a kill zone
had you guys had anyone wounded prior to
that yes uh
uh
randy randy sheridan had been seriously
wounded uh
he uh he basically lost his elbow
as a result of the one that he got on on
one of my squad operations
had you guys had anyone killed in your
platoon no
oh yeah and uh you know
you know
i feel fortunate to be able to talk
about the operation bone 31 uh january
uh 1970 30 january 1971
uh
because nobody was killed uh with that
number of bad guys uh and without the uh
uh the the the flying and the dedication
of uh
hal three uh
carl nelson in particular and uh and his
uh you know his door gunners uh
i'm not here to have the conversation
so i it's uh it's interesting to be able
to have that conversation uh
any uh any smart ass remarks that i
might uh make about it call it seal
humor uh but uh you know that's that's
what it is uh i'm happy to be alive i'm
glad those guys are alive too
yeah
um
and then that ended up being the last
mission that you guys did
absolutely there was nobody left to go
anywhere uh we uh and uh
unfortunately uh
there was not much of a debrief uh you
know we were all there and uh
were we all there being two i think
except marcus uh marcus said uh
marcus
went
well i don't know what his uh his uh his
evac process was but uh the rest of us
were there in uh in uh in
ben tui third field surgical hospital uh
you know together for a few days but
then then we went different directions
in the uh in the process uh
jim roland went one one place i came
back to san diego i don't remember where
grant went uh but uh you know i
basically jesus i don't know how many
years it was before i i saw grant again
it was just one of those deals
how bad was your hand messed up i can't
imagine getting shot in the hands
it seems like
for you to be totally mobile with your
hands
just get lucky uh
yeah i got lucky and you know when when
you tell somebody that you were wounded
people wanna you know you know people
are almost hesitant to ask about your
war wing because they figure you're
gonna pull down your pants and show
where you're shot in the ass you know
but i've i've i've got a better one
because i was i was holding holding on
to the pistol grip
of a uh of a machine gun
the round went through
the end of my thumb through my finger
you can see how the uh
nail there is uh somewhat damaged
and then through the uh through the hand
and just shattered the uh the bones in
the hand
so
i was a radio man at this point in time
and uh
i was fortunate i was able to use my
thumb my index finger uh in order to uh
to operate the handset because the the
end of the end of my middle finger was
no good my ring finger was no good and
neither was my uh my pinky finger so i
had i had two fingers to uh to work the
radio with and uh you know i was
fortunate to be able to do that
in uh
in grant telfer's recounting of how
uh this uh this went down he said uh
you know he he heard me uh yelp or
scream when i uh first got hit and uh
then he uh then he mentions and uh in
the summary that he provided for uh
uh captain slattery uh he heard you know
tom uh yelp a second time
well let me tell you about that second
time
uh
we've all seen uh people like uh john
wayne or uh what's the name clint
eastwood uh get get wounded and you know
go on and do great wonderful things
and i don't remember if it was two mules
with sister sarah where uh you know
eastwood takes an arrow in the shoulder
and he
puts a little gunpowder on the you know
hole in the front of his uh shoulder in
the hole in the back of the shoulder and
pulls the arrow back out through
so i said hey should
eastwood could do it i can do it so i
looked down at my hand
after i got hit
and i see what i thought was the bullet
sticking out of the back of my hand
so hey you know let's just take a second
and take care of this so i reach down
and i grab what i thought was the bullet
between my teeth
and i and i just give it a good yank to
uh to get that bullet out of there
well it was one of my finger bones
and that finger bone was still attached
that's as grant heard me yelp the second
time
[Laughter]
i mean i don't know what the pain is
like giving birth but i'm telling you
that was that was absolutely amazing i
swear to god my toes curled
and
but that's the kind of guy you have in
the teams that's who the [ __ ] we are
yeah okay i got a hole in my hand that's
a bullet let me get rid of the bullet
you know
there's an old saying you [ __ ] with the
truck and you get dumped right
that's who the special forces are
if you want somebody to go in there and
do the job you want somebody to ignore
pain and do what it is that they're
supposed to do
1 800
special operations
uh
you're coming home now from vietnam
did you know the war was gonna did you
know that was probably gonna be your
last deployment
no i didn't and uh quite frankly i uh i
got
got that information sort of like as a
surprise
uh
my uh you know
when i was first wounded they told me
they were probably going to have to have
a second operation on my hand to restore
you know full function
so i i get to balboa hospital and they
uh they unwrap the uh the cast and so on
and and they say uh you you we don't
think you're going to be able to uh to
move your ring finger and so i moved my
ring finger and you know not a whole lot
of strength there of course but i said
oh well you know
if you don't think we need to go in
again uh and you know straighten out the
uh the bones and so on it seems to be
functioning uh uh
just go through a recovery process and
you're good to go so
i uh i said well if i don't have to have
another operation on my hand that's good
for me
and uh so i went through the rehab and i
as soon as soon as i was given a medical
clearance that i was good to go
i went back into the exo's office and
said
xo sign me up
and he said uh
tom uh
i'm afraid freddie can't do that uh the
uh the war is starting to wind down as
you just said jocko and uh
the uh
leadership rightly so wanted to make
sure that
a bunch of guys
a bunch of guys the rest of the guys who
had not had actual combat experience
would have that opportunity for that
exposure
let's make sure we understand
opportunity exposure and the required
experience that you want in your
military fighting forces so
the the co and the exo we're getting as
many new guys the opportunity to deploy
and get that exposure to
holy [ __ ] i'm gonna die or maybe i'm
gonna live
uh and live through it and you're a
different person that's what they were
trying to do exo tells me that uh
unfortunately i'm not gonna be able to
become a member of another platoon and i
said well
i i'm out of here
i can't i can't stay here and watch
these guys go do what i want to do
so at that point in time
i went through a
decision process
trying to figure out
do i get out of the navy
uh
if i do what do i do border patrol
fbi
uh you know what what's uh what's gonna
be uh
do i do i stay in the teams
if i do what do i do
and so
i uh
i went from seal team one to the
training center as the diving officer uh
and uh
that was a uh
it was a great experience uh you know
dealing with the uh the kids the new
guys
kids new guys they're like four year the
officers are like three or four years
younger than me right
so uh i uh i had that job it was a it
was a great experience
so i said well i'll stick around for a
little while longer and yeah ended up
being 30 years
but i was i was really i was really
disappointed not to get the opportunity
to go back
and as you know i went to el salvador
when
lieutenant commander schofelberger was
killed
and
as soon as i heard about al's death
i raised my hand
and
i was surprised that there weren't a few
more people raising their hand but
i raised my hand to go go down there i
mean that's where
that's where my trade and my experience
and my skills were going to be needed in
some way shape or form i want to do that
that's why i signed up
so before you went down to el salvador
so you did you went to buds for a little
while as a dive phase officer i had a
two year two year tour at buds and uh
one of the things that i felt was a uh
was a failure on the on the mission
where we all got uh got wounded there in
the 30th of january
was an intelligence failure so from buds
i went to defense intelligence school it
was a nine-month program back at uh
at the navy yard in uh in washington d.c
actually the anacostia annex
nine-month program and from there i went
to uh two years as the as the intel
officer at naval special warfare group
two
uh
then i got to uh to team one to team two
as the as the ops officer and uh
uh that's where i met folks like uh
uh bruce fan heard him dick marcinko uh
uh
you name it uh all the uh cast
characters uh bob uh was it bob bob
wagner the uh navy cross
navy cross winner from uh one of the
navy cross winners from seal team two
was uh was running the uh the training
program uh at uh at team two and he was
uh he was a uh
he was just uh hard as now son of a
[ __ ] uh you know you know great guy he
wanted to make sure that the guys were
trained and ready to go and do what uh
do what they needed to do
what was the uh at this time in this
late 70s i mean there'd just be
no money for the seals i'm imagining no
like what was the
as the as the as the navy drew down you
know during like the carter years what
was that like
seeing as i'm not sure
if the navy can stop my pension
i have a hard time answering that
question
when when i came back from vietnam uh we
had before i left to go to uh the be the
diving officer
uh the navy was uh the navy was tearing
down uh its uh
brown water navy uh and and they they
weren't really thinking about special
operations they were just thinking about
brown water navy
uh
the uh
you you interviewed uh
carl nelson from uh from hal three
the helicopter attack light squadrons
that were set up in vietnam were
commissioned in vietnam and
disestablished in vietnam never even
came back to the united states
there was not a commitment
by the navy to support special
operations aviation assets
when i came back
uh
seal team one had a uh had a directive
to
reduce end strength uh by it was either
30 or 34 the oh yeah they sent guys to
the fleet right they sent them back to
the fleet
the the expression that sticks in my
mind was a 30-34 as we called them might
have been the dirty 30 but it was 30 or
34 guys
uh and uh
you know
uh
bruce bruce van heard him and uh
george worthington uh you know god rest
his soul george uh just passed away but
can you imagine you know
somebody in in the navy where reducing
end strengths comes down and they tell
uh commander worthington and lieutenant
commander van hernam
okay you got a [ __ ] can
34 your guys who've just been through
some of the most difficult training in
the world and uh and and send them back
to the fleet
uh
they they came up with the best
uh
set of criteria that they could at the
time
for people who had only been in the team
for a certain period of time guys with
no deployments uh guys under the rank of
such and such you know uh there were
there were a number of those things but
they did they did the best that they
could but it sucked
uh and and a bunch of those guys came
back uh probably most of those guys came
back
uh but what that shows i just said about
the the house situation uh the seal team
won and i'm sure seal team two went
through the same thing uh i actually
have never talked to anybody about that
but
uh you look at the uh at the green
berets they uh the army was were tossing
those guys left and right so
the military
did not understand the department of
defense state department did not
understand what was going on in the
world and the and the type of conflicts
we were going to see coming down the
road
to your point there in the 70s it was a
it was a period of time when not much
was going on but you turn around and you
start looking at at el salvador and
other locations uh
the the operations we uh we did down
there in panama
uh you know things things are starting
to look pretty pretty stinky uh around
the around the rest of the world
and you're not gonna send an aircraft
carrier or battleship to do that
you're gonna send somebody like us
and uh you even fast forward to the uh
to the to the gulf wars you know
multiple
uh
who was it that was getting uh you know
most of the assignments uh every once in
a while a uh
ship or submarine would launch a few
missiles on a particular strike
but
you know who was uh
who was getting all the uh who was
getting all the press who was doing all
the missions
naval special operations navy special
warfare
uh we've uh
we've evolved as you asked me earlier
about the some of the types of missions
done then as compared to now uh we've
evolved incredibly and that that
evolution is is absolutely key
we today
are the same people
that we were
50 years ago jesus on
time flies we're we are today the same
guys as we were 50 years ago
the guys who figure out how to get it
done
uh you know people like to use the term
out of the box thinking
if you think there is the box you're
already constrained
there is no box and as we move forward
people people wonder about what it is
about naval special warfare we are
problem solvers we need we figure out
how to get it
we are given some of the most difficult
missions there are
in the
inventory of missions
and told to get told to figure out how
to do them
sure we draw in all kinds of other
specialties but that's exactly what we
do we draw in you know look at that
whole business with uh you know bin
laden
uh you know that wasn't all us but look
at what was brought to bear when we went
from
incredible intelligence assets
incredible aviation assets incredible
planning assets our guys figured out how
to fly behind mountains and out of out
of radar signatures so
so the host nation wouldn't even know we
were there that takes a lot of
innovation problem solving
when i talk to people about who the
military is what we do people think of
us as you know you know bullet launchers
tank drivers airplane drivers
you know submarine skippers they don't
understand all the planning and thought
and problem solving
personal management you name it that
goes into having a successful successful
unit it's not it's not just pushing the
button and launching a missile that the
general dynamics might have built it's
all the other planning that goes on
before and after that is so important
it's what sets that sets the military
aside
so when you let's talk about el salvador
and this is one of the small conflicts
that was going on
um how how did you end up getting down
there
well uh unfortunately i was at a uh in a
team party uh back in may of 1983
and people were shooting the breeze and
it turned out that uh lieutenant
commander al shafferberger who was you
know serving a tour down there as a
seal member of the military advisory
group had been assassinated
uh
boy there's there's so much that i can i
can say about that uh
i learned
i've had i've had the opportunity to
have some great jobs in the navy uh each
one of them i've learned so many things
and you you don't have enough time to
listen
uh but uh
look look at el salvador uh so i've uh
out gets killed i volunteered to replace
them
and i was a commanding officer of
special boat unit 13 at the time
great opportunity so the requirement for
the guy for uh you know replacing al
salforberger was they wanted seal
experience they wanted boat experience
and they wanted the guy to be able to
speak spanish
they also wanted the guy to be a
volunteer well
when the uh when my name was forwarded
to the uh uh
uh to the commander of the military
advisory group he said well three out of
four ain't bad because i didn't i didn't
speak spanish
but uh i i had had the other stuff down
but that's exactly what i did as i
mentioned a little bit earlier that's
that's why i went to naval special
warfare that's what i wanted to do you
know the uh you know
uh
one of the uh one of the guys that uh
seal team one
had his uh when i was a skipper had uh
had his brother come out and they were
running around and uh uh
did pt with us and so on and so forth
and uh this guy says to his brother the
seal uh he says who is that guy it looks
like uh
there ought to be a sign there it says
in case of war break glass
and uh
he told me about that and and i had to
laugh but that's what i want to say
about each and every guy in the teams in
case of war break glass so that's why i
went down to uh that went down to
salvador uh i wanted to see what was
going on
i had two or three weeks of uh
personalized
spanish training
and
but i was the outgoing commanding
officer of a unit
i had because it was active and
and reserve i had
x number of active and i had three time
that many reserve officer fitness
reports you know chief evaluations to
get to get out uh and the other thing is
a lot of those guys did things that
deserved recognition during the period
of time that i was commanding officer so
i had awards to uh to get written up and
so it was uh
it was a hard period of time it didn't
get a whole hell of a lot of spanish
but by the time i left el salvador i was
dreaming in spanish how long were you
down there i was down here for a full
year uh but uh it was uh
uh i first got down there and i working
in the embassy uh whether they were
americans or
uh you know salvadorans they all had to
speak fluent english
so
we could get business done because
numbnuts here couldn't speak spanish uh
we could get business done speak in
english and
i tried
tried
doing it all in in spanish when i first
got there and
uh
it was enough of a uh of a delay i said
okay we'll we'll work on this gradually
you know yeah habla and glaze so we uh
we we went and uh we we spoke english
but
that was one of the most exciting times
that i've uh that i've ever had in the
military uh
i got down there and there was a there
was a civil war going on the uh the mill
group commander a guy named joe string
and colonel joe stringham
smoking joe stringham uh
the uh
uh
i don't want to say the guy was on speed
[Music]
i i don't know what made this man take
that man
never slowed down that smoking joe i
mean you know peripatetic hyperkinetic
you pick your term that was uh that was
joe i couldn't keep up with the man and
i thought i was pretty good so i get
down there i'm there for about 10 days
or two weeks and i have i've you know
taken over the job that uh
al was doing part-time
uh
and uh um i'm i'm the exo at the uh at
the office as well as a navy rep
and uh
there's a there's a uh a retired or
i don't know hilda hilda wasn't in the
air force long enough uh
hilda the secretary uh was uh uh
uh a hispanic american and uh
she was uh
uh
a piece of work she brought out this
piece of paper that colonel stringham
had written you know this is the colonel
wants me to type this up i can't read
this and so uh hilda and i were going
over this particular piece of paper and
said the only reason i could make sense
of it and figure out what it was
was because i had been part of the
conversation and knew what he was trying
to do but that's i mean he didn't he
didn't have he didn't have time to to
write that right clearly so 10 days
after i'm down there i finally you know
he's
my position as i could i could see uh
see the daughter's office and maybe even
see see partly into his office
and
colonel stringham is getting ready to uh
to go off back over to the estado mayor
the estado mayor is is their
equivalent of the joint chiefs of staff
uh he worked with the uh all the uh the
leadership of the
salvadoran military he's getting ready
to blast off and go over to the estado
mayor
and uh
i was
not at my lifting peak but i was uh
i was you know
pretty big but almost jocko's size
and uh
uh colonel stringham was a few inches
shorter and uh you know you know a good
50 pounds you know maybe 60 pounds
lighter so i just stood in the door
and i said
colonel
we got to talk
i got to have some left and right
margins
and so he said okay come on over the
house today all right so uh but uh that
was a fantastic year
colonel stringham spent his time working
very closely with the estado mayor
because as you remember there were
things like death squads going on uh
before uh before i got down there and
before the colonel got down there uh
i think there had been a uh a number of
uh nuns who'd been kidnapped raped
killed and all that other stuff and it
was being blamed on some of the
salvadoran armed forces not the bad guys
but this i would argue so colonel string
was doing everything that he could to
provide that uh
u.s
influence on on on how to conduct
warfare uh and so in order to do that he
needs to spend a lot of his time over
there
so i ended up being the stuck e in the
embassy
uh and when i said
when i'd say stuckey you know that meant
this
this meeting that came up and that
meeting that came up or this delegation
coming down to salvador and and so on
and so forth
so
it was a wonderful opportunity let me
drift right back to ray smith for a
second
uh
secretary armitage uh named rachel
armitage was a naval academy graduate
uh and uh you know
secretary armitage at the time was the
assistant secretary of defense for
international security affairs i think
it was
he had a couple of active duty military
assistants
ray smith his classmate from uh from the
naval academy and and another guy so
uh
international security affairs is what
paid for uh what goes on uh you know
what money comes to uh to el salvador
and they they monitor it and review it
and so on and it was a lot of money at
this time it was it was a lot billion
billions of dollars for going down i i
don't remember the uh the numbers but uh
and i should because i can't tell you
how many how many hours or weeks i spent
going over the numbers this that and the
other thing
so about uh
after we had that conversation uh you
know colonel and i uh yeah so i'm i'm in
country you know no more than three
weeks no more than four weeks
and uh
secretary of defense comes down to visit
kasper weinberger
secretary weinberger comes down and
assistant secretary uh uh
armitage is with him
and
in my
uh accelerated preparation to go down to
uh el salvador i went to a couple of
courses and there was this air force uh
was a major at the time uh anyway he and
i became friends in this three-week
course
at air force base and uh he ends up
being an assistant to uh uh
to weinberger
so weinberger comes down for the uh for
the uh for the full full treatment and
and i'm i'm handling the backside of
operations making sure that you know
everybody's where they're supposed to be
yeah
and uh
so i didn't have any contact with uh
with armitage you know uh you know
weinberger this you know air force major
uh that i had met
colonel uh colonel stringham comes back
we're having a debrief of the day and
first thing out of his mouth is it says
who are you
what do you mean who are you
he said
three or four people
on the secretary of defense staff today
asked me how's tom richards doing who
are you
so
so i said to him i said well
one of my uh one of my bud's classmates
is a special assistant to uh you know uh
you know secretary armitage and uh you
know uh if we ever needed to play an ace
in the hole and things weren't quite
going right yeah and i could always call
ray and uh you know he'd i'd be more
than happy to help figure out how to
unscrew something
and string him just shook his head
but
one of the uh
there's any number of stories uh you may
recall that we had a limitation on the
number of
advisors
we could have in country at a at a given
point in time and that number happened
to be 55 and as i say there's a number
of stories about how that number came up
be that as it may that was a number that
we had to live with
i can count to 55 in my sleep
starting with my left hand my right hand
my left foot my right foot
if we had 56
american military individuals in country
the press was all over us like a
hangover on saturday morning oh you're
not living up to your obligation you're
trying to get too many trainers in
country you're doing this
bottom line is
my job my ass was
gonna lose a chunk
if number 66 was in in country
we were at some points in time we had
guys getting off the airplane in uh at
the uh at the salvadoran air force you
know base
and other guys getting on at the same
time just to make sure we stayed at 55
and
at one point in time we had a series of
challenges security challenges in
country
uh i had my go bag packed i always had
my go backpack that 55 include like the
embassy security marines and all that no
that's where i was going to go
the the marines had a security
detachment and it was one of the largest
it was
oh 25 28 guys it was it was a large uh
you know marine security detachment
and so you had the marine security
detachment you had the military advisory
group staff
so that was me the colonel uh
ms martinez uh
you know a couple of uh you know
three four
uh
army officers and air force officers who
were
five six uh air force officers who were
uh army and air force officers who were
doing uh various things as part of the
mill group staff then you also had the
defense at day's office defense attached
office
uh there are only a handful of guys over
there having no more than half a dozen
so
uh
we had a meeting at the at the embassy
we called everybody in to get everybody
in uniform on the same page uh it was
about you know
security kinds of things uh and of
course
there's a half a dozen uh
uh media personnel always keeping an
eyeball on they counted
and there was no way we had 55 of our
advisors there but we had a bunch of our
advisors there we had a bunch of the
marines there we had our uh mill group
staff we had our
attache staff so they counted well over
55 uh you know you know military guys
and uh
so i spent part of a press conference
explaining to them you know who these
people are and how they count and how
close attention we do pay to that paid
to that number uh but that was a real
real pain in the uh in the butt
so so as i mentioned i'm talking to the
uh to the press about that
mrs richard's little boy tommy did not
go to salvador prepared to be you know
fielding questions from the washington
post the new york times san diego union
i mean give me a break
uh
i was a fast learner though
but it was uh it was uh it was difficult
you know they had they had they had a
they had an agenda
and uh
i had a uh i had a mission
and so uh i won't say never the twain
shall meet uh but uh i had to
i had to be very careful with uh with my
answers and i had to uh
debunk a number of their of their
concerns
while i was there and i apologize for
not being able to recall a man's name
there was actually a reporter from san
diego who was killed uh on a on a battle
zone
and
of course the colonel was over at the
estado mayor so i was taking that next
press conference
and
i'm saying that they you know one of the
things they
press
complained about was the the number of
uh
uh
what they were calling non-combatant
injuries
that were occurring and of course this
reporters and your ear death is uh his
is his non-combatant as you can get
but i try to explain to them there's a
fire fight going on there there's a
gunfight going out there these these
bullets when they come out of the end of
the gun that are aimed by people are not
necessarily the best marksmen that they
are that there could be these bullets
don't have name tags on them and uh you
know it's hard to tell where they're
gonna go and who's gonna get hit
one of the things that the that the
guerrillas did because they were you
know gorillas and they didn't have the
the kind of funding that you might have
wanted to have was uh when the shooters
the guys are out there one of the guys
gets hit fall down
one of the women or one of the kids go
right out onto the battle zone to
collect the gun
and the bullets for the other guys so
they still have
weapons and ammunition to carry out the
fight
they're right there in the middle of the
of the fire fight of course they're
gonna get hit it isn't our decision that
they choose to make them combatants but
that's what they have done they're no
longer women and children they are they
are combatants they are right there on
the on the combat zone that's the kind
of thing that these different countries
with these different senses of values do
to the americans
and and they do it uh
throughout the uh throughout the middle
east they were doing it in in salvador
and that's the type of battles
that our
young servicemen
are forced into you take an american kid
whether he's come out of high school or
college what do we talk about today
we've got uh we've got uh
uh you know women's rights we've got
gays rights we have uh
equal opportunity uh you know
lgbtq whatever the whatever the variety
of things are that
our youth of today is drilled to be so
aware of and so conscious of
uh we treat women in the united states
uh
my wife weighs about a buck 18 or a buck
20. if i was to raise my hand to that
lady i'd break her in half
i've never even thought about it in
foreign countries they use women as
flak jackets to protect themselves from
from bullets coming in
those kinds of
things are so
antithetical to what we think and we
believe as americans and yet we take
this kid out of uh you know uh peoria or
uh yeah you know pick your uh you know
uh
central united states or central
american values we take this person and
we put them in the middle of this
shitstorm this this soup of total
disregard for human rights and human
life human values
and uh you know we we do this to people
on a on a daily basis
uh that's uh
that's the kind of thing that i really
first encountered in vietnam
saw it brought home again in el salvador
uh you know being on the uh being on the
ground
as i was so we we do some pretty
interesting things to our uh to our
youth of america by throwing them into
this cauldron of of discontent that we
do
i could i could go on and go on for that
one uh a little bit more but uh that's
uh
that's a uh that's an incredible thing
so i will go on with that for just a
little bit more
let me talk about something people call
ptsd
and i won't use some of my
terminology on your on your podcast
but
we need to lose the d
let's just go back to my day in the rice
paddy in uh january of uh of 71
i got don futrell with a bullet hole in
his chest
i got grant telfer shot in both legs
i got jim roland with a bullet hole in
his chest and his groin
my hand is you know looks like a uh
looks like kind of you know you know raw
hamburger you know left and uh left in a
pile of juice
i'm not ever
going to unsee that
i'll say that i don't mind
and i really don't because we had signed
up to do that that's what we're there
for
but people today are coming back from uh
from wars and they're seeing far worse
they're seeing
roadside uh
ieds you know uh
supposedly uh impenetrable uh you know
armored vehicles you know you know
ripped apart like a uh like like a beer
can and and and the parts of the people
inside of that that they try to drag to
safety if they happen to be a survivor
and they just watch bleed out
or the or the corpsmen that have to deal
with that on a daily basis
you cannot
unsee
any of that
it's not going to go away you look at
our first responders of today
you've got a you got a knife fight
you've got a gunfight you've got a fire
at a house you've got a gas explosion
what do those people see they see
fellow members of their township or
whatever their association is
in parts
blood everywhere you know sometimes
human forms
irrecognizable if there is such a term
you're never going to unsee those things
so let's not talk about
post-traumatic stress as a disorder
if you don't have some
thoughts some concerns if you didn't
wish your fellow american wasn't such a
jackass at times to cause this kind of
hate discontent pain and misery on other
people if you didn't have some
form of thought process of again regret
that
that these things happen wish they
didn't happen wish that you didn't
happen to see it
if you didn't have those kinds of
thoughts
that's the disorder
you know
i tell my wife that
i don't have any post-traumatic stress
i don't have any flashbacks
you can call me a lion mother but uh uh
you know i there are things
we were standing outside a uh a dinner
theater shortly after i came back from
vietnam
car backfired
jackie looked
where am i
i'm on the ground
i'm looking for what the problem is
where it came from what i need to do
about it
i wouldn't call that post-traumatic
stress i'd say that's good training
but as we as as we look at all these uh
all these individuals who come back from
these situations and i want to i want to
include the first responders who face
these things every day
as as we look at these people we need to
understand
we will never understand some of the
things that they cannot unsee
but we need to understand that they have
been in those situations
and we have put them there
we the american people sent choco and
myself the rest of us to various places
around the world we never could find on
the map before we went there
to do things to try to support people in
democratic pursuits
and [ __ ] happens and it's not it's not
pretty
but yet we do that to the youth of
america time and time again so we need
to understand that this post-traumatic
stress exists it's not a disorder and we
need to make sure that we address it
so
what did you when you when you came home
from vietnam and like you know you just
talked that story about the the uh
gunfire or the backfire in the car
what about the rest of your platoon it
sounds like you guys kind of went to the
four wins in all in different directions
we sure did i think i mentioned earlier
in the in the podcast that uh
i hadn't seen grant telfer for you know
you know 15 20 years maybe even more
after that and he he later became a
commanding officer of seal team one
while he was in that position i was on
the uh on the east coast uh and uh years
later i i bumped into uh
into jim roland uh
and uh don futrell went to uh went into
eod
another one of those easy
easy warfare specialties uh he went into
eod and
don retired as a as a w-4 but
uh shortly after after he went uh left a
platoon uh i i lost track of don i knew
he went into eod but
we reconnected and i i spoke at his
retirement uh but you know crap
that was
not much to say for uh for uh you know
keeping tabs on your platoon members
other guys got out uh
marcus arroyo was a uh was a highly
successful uh you know uh um uh
executive in the uh uh i believe was the
f uh faa or it was the tf faa i believe
uh and uh you know so
uh but but we lost track of each other
and so we're really uh
uh i know i am really looking forward to
seeing some of those guys again here uh
this weekend
but those guys you know they they
carried on right so whatever pts
they had they were able to say okay this
is my this is what i'm going to do now
i'm going to go to the faa or i'm going
to get out and go to eod
and and we're able to kind of push
through those whatever what is whatever
was going on in their heads
that appears to be that appears to be
the case and of course not of course uh
jim roland got out of the navy for a
little bit after uh uh after vietnam but
he came back uh and retired as a senior
chief
so let's go back you get you get home
from el salvador what's next on
on the agenda
uh let's see where do i go from el
salvador i came i came back here to
beautiful sunny southern california uh
and i uh i was i was on the staff of uh
special warfare group one and uh
i work for a couple of folks uh who end
up being flag officers uh
chuck lemoine and uh
uh
george worthington uh a couple of a
couple of good guys and and of course
meta got a whole lot of other good good
guys and and and what i'll say uh what i
need to say here is
when i retired that's what i miss most
the guys i miss the guys and of course
knowing what was going on in the world
but you missed the guys you miss miss
the organization the association
so i went to uh
i went to uh to group one
uh and from group one i went over to uh
to be ceo of seal team one
now that's almost like cheating because
i was the operations officer at group
one so i knew i knew how the group staff
worked uh i knew how the group commander
worked uh and and uh when i say the
staff just just how it functions who did
what to whom
and uh so who you could call to build
those little relationships right and uh
uh
uh admiral worthington and admiral des
moines uh
had a uh and several other guys who were
the commander there
had a secretary by the name of lena and
i am i'm embarrassed i can remember his
last name but lena was was a piece of
work
uh
lena knew everything
and if you were good and elena
you learned a lot uh but i remember uh i
uh you know one day uh uh you know
i think it was uh it was lemoine
uh lemoyne comes out to lena and you
know all right i want this this this and
this
lena
knows that sounds kind of familiar she
comes trotting into my office and we uh
you know we try to piece it together and
figure out you know she had some of the
files for that and i had some of the
files but uh you know she was uh she was
uh you know quite a quite a young lady
it's a young lady older lady uh but uh
there were some great folks on that
staff and like i said it's kind of like
cheating uh to have that chance before i
went to seal team one
and then your ceo of seal team one for a
couple years and this is
what what years are you the ceo of steel
team won 86 to 88 okay and uh during
that period of time i had the chance to
deploy to the persian gulf
the uh
the oil rigs and the counter iranian
right stuff right
so we had uh uh we had two uh uh
uh two barges uh that were really oil
rigs support barges
we use those as floating
floating operations bases for
a couple of elements of you know a
couple aviation
elements
i think their
participation was later declassified but
we'll just leave it at that a couple of
uh you know aviation elements and of
course we had our our patrol boats and
our patrol boats were you know doing
escorts uh of uh
of u.s navy big holes they were also
doing escorts of
tankers you know
as you may recall
a number of those
foreign flag ships were reflagged to u.s
ships so we could actually
excuse me we could actually escort them
up and down the uh up and down the gulf
what was was there any
highlights to those deployments
there were a number of them uh
we had uh you may there's a uh uh paul
evanco led an op on uh
uh something on a boat called the iran
ajar and the iran ajar
uh trying to
uh seed a few more mines after you know
iran had been been told
stop what you're doing
anyway they
they conducted the op uh you know it
sees the seize the boat a bunch of mines
and so on
well
fast forward you know several months
later i'm out there as the uh the task
unit uh commander
and uh we get a report of a uh of a
craft
in restricted waters
and it looks like there might be mine
like objects on the back end of this
boat and that this is another group
going to be laying mines in the sea
lanes
so we go to
gq we uh we launched some of these
aviation assets to try to get some uh
night shots of the uh
uh
of the of the boat in question
and uh
it was uh
it was coming up you know coming up
towards dawn
and uh
you know obviously you know those early
hours uh are the
good time to at the hit folks some folks
are getting up some folks are going off
a watch some folks are eating
so a good time to to make a hit if
you're going to do that
so they came back
and they had some
they had some some pictures
and uh sure look like mine like objects
but you know
you got that little we call it spidey
sense
something's not quite right with this
picture and one of the things that i
always say to the guys
if you think that there's something
wrong with this picture you stop what
you're doing and to figure until you
figure out what is wrong with this
picture
so
we got guys locked and loaded we got the
uh we got the slicks we got the gun
ships these guys are ready to go take
down these boats this boat
and i said
hold fast
we're not going anywhere
give me one more shot at the at the
early twilight
it turned out to be
another
oil rig supply boat
that had a bunch of 55 gallon drums not
mines on the after deck
i won't say what country it was from
they were in waters where they shouldn't
have been
they have no idea how close to death
they came
so i'm sitting out there i'm
i'm in the talk i'm i'm i'm monitoring
all the uh the communications
and and i'm the i'm the one that you
know we had these guys in the air said
you know
and uh
the uh the three star navy type uh who
was in charge of uh of uh
uh you know mid-east foreign
navy minister
uh
he uh
i didn't realize it but he was in the
talk the whole time uh you know
listening uh you know i'm sure the the
lasalle uh was uh
uh was based in bahrain we're out there
in the middle of the persian gulf
and uh the uh
uh the admiral was there you're just
listening and listening and uh you know
uh
when i when i called it off when i saw
what it was you just
went yeah
and uh went in so i i came i came ashore
uh you know
a week 10 days later and
the 06 uh you know opso calls me over
and he says
good job
but uh you know we had we had american
lives on the line we had international
lives on the line uh could have been a
mining operation i just did not know uh
and uh i was not sure that this was a
minor uh the mind laying uh vessel so i
said nope we're not doing that
what were your major lessons learned or
what was like a good take away from
being the commanding officer at till
team one
uh
trying to train
the guys are gonna follow me
prepare them for their jobs
uh
there was uh a platoon uh with uh
uh
dave piddlecow who's the commanding uh
commander of the platoon
and uh gardner howe was his assistant uh
that would be vice admiral how
was his assistant and they were going
over to the gulf uh and uh
as they're in my uh in my uh in my
office getting ready to go
uh one of the things i explained to him
is that i feel that you guys are as
prepared as you can possibly be
to go over there and to conduct the
litany of operations that you would be
called upon to do
but i said to him i said
my fervent hope is
that that doesn't happen
and i got these two confused looks
or
inquisitive looks
from these two
you know gung-ho
seal officers who were you know getting
ready to go to war
because it wasn't the shooting war at
that point in time
and what i explained to him was
if you guys have got to do the things
that we've trained you and prepared you
to do
that means
that somebody has failed
big time
uh and so uh that was a
learning experience for uh for dave and
gardner uh but it was one of the things
that i tried to uh
try to impart to those guys you know
there's there's
well in case of br in case of glass
excuse glass in case of war break glass
that's us
absolutely
but if it devolves to that point that
means
that
white house policy has failed uh the
state department policy has failed uh
any number of things uh across the
spectrum of the leadership of our
country has failed so
it is truly in case a war break class
one of the uh
that same platoon as it turned out as
they're preparing to uh
uh preparing to get ready to uh to go
overseas uh you have any number of uh
your training operations and uh you know
where
we those of us in the teams are familiar
with something we call a rubber duck uh
a rubber duck is a uh is a air drop of a
uh
of a small rubber boat uh on a uh on a
on a platform as it were drops out in
the ocean and you uh you sink the
platform and
from that point in the ocean you go
ashore and you uh do your job and if
everything worked all right everybody
everybody else in the world doesn't know
that the uh
c-130 or 141 might have dropped this uh
you know boat and seals off the uh off
the coast
well they uh
they had a uh a rubber duck drop uh you
know practice event
and uh
there was a uh
parachute rigging malfunction and
instead of the parachute deploying the
uh the rubber duck creamed into the
ocean you know the uh the uh the
platform breaks into uh a thousand
pieces the uh the boat is shredded the
outboard motor is lost etcetera etcetera
so uh i had not stayed up uh for estate
at the commander uh for the uh for the
event
but i get to the
the command about seven o'clock in the
morning
and uh
i get a uh
i get a a high speed uh you know five
minute uh brief that the uh
the rubber duck died
and uh it was a uh
it was a rigging malfunction
so
uh
before
seven o'clock is before quarters our day
at uh team one started with quarters at
7 30.
so
uh it's it's about 7 15.
before i could even
get to
uh lieutenant pedal cow or lieutenant
howe
uh
the parachute rigger
from the squad comes in
bangs on my door
petty officer second class bacchus
bacchus apologizes
to the commanding officer of the team
for letting his platoon down
for letting my platoon down for not
meeting the expectations of uh of uh of
everybody
that they had for
bacchus and the uh the troops to do that
job
when bacchus came into the t into my
office to do that
that told me that i clearly had
some level of communication
with the guys
some
level of respect
from the guys
that before i could go out and try to
rip him a new one
he shows up
at my office and apologizes
you know
that told me that i must have done
something right at seal team one because
that was that was probably one of the
greatest
experiences from team one
you have people taking ownership and
that that's a an attitude that starts at
the top yep
so
you wrap up at seal team one um
and then
you your next big command is taking over
buds
that was uh that was my uh my next uh
uh my next opportunity i spent
i spent three years at uh
naval sea systems command
learning a lot about money purchasing
and all that other kind of stuff
and
i followed a guy by him tommy hawkins
who was a legend in the world of our
research development and acquisition and
even though i left that job as a quote
certified navy acquisition professional
i was i was offered jobs
in the acquisition side of the house i
was offered the opportunity to take jobs
and acquisition as opposed to uh
continuing uh in in naval special
warfare so yeah and i could have been a
program manager at navsea or as i went
to uh you know the the job at the uh at
the center but uh
i know i probably never learned as much
as tommy hawkins uh knew about uh knew
about acquisition uh quite a uh quite a
guy
so yes my my next uh my next uh my next
command was uh was at uh at the center
and there a couple of things were really
really fun about the center
you watch
young men come in there and they're not
entirely sure what they're getting into
and they're also not entirely sure
whether they can do this or not
they're pretty sure they can that's why
they're there in the first place
they really want to which is why they're
there
but a lot of folks have a uh have a
little bit of a uh a nagging doubt
and uh
a lot of those guys success
uh is uh
at times a uh
somewhat of a surprise perhaps to their
parents uh but a uh in in many cases uh
a uh
an achievement of of great great pride
on the uh on the parents part
and as the uh as a commanding officer of
the uh the center
one of the things that i did was i
attended every buds graduation now again
this was uh this was when buds was the
uh was the six months before he went on
to the uh the follow-on uh sqt i believe
it's still called these days
uh so they would com they would complete
the uh uh the six months and then they
would go to the various teams for that
follow-on training before they received
their special warfare designator
anyway
i cannot tell you how many parents would
come up to me at these graduation events
and they would say uh
you know captain richards uh you know we
really want to thank you and your staff
for uh what you have done for uh you
know for frank or uh or echo or gary and
uh and their uh and their development
and their maturation process
uh you know the he's a uh he's a changed
man after these uh yeah six uh six eight
months
i said no
mrs smith
you really have to understand
we took
what you gave us
an individual who
had some pretty high aspirations and you
taught him to have those high
aspirations
we taught up the individual who thought
he had the qualifications and you helped
him develop these qualifications you
might have thought he was a little bit
of a misfit here and there i'm probably
speaking from personal experience
but you prepared this this young man to
uh to get there
we wouldn't have
this young petty officer or this young
ensign graduating from seal training if
it hadn't been for you
and you know these parents would just
kind of look at me
and look at each other
hmm yeah you know maybe there's uh maybe
there's something to that
but
that's a that that's a point that i
would really like to make that the
individual
who is who graduates after now it's a
year
uh but that individual
came to buds
with a certain amount of preparation a
significant amount of preparation
and it's preparation that reflects
family values
family uh you know family motivation uh
family support for a uh for an
individual and i can remember some we
never thought he was gonna be any good
you know we kept trying and trying you
know he always kept getting in trouble
and whatever it might have been
and that's my point you kept trying and
trying and trying and look where he is
now yeah he said that's your fault
and uh you know they'd stop and they
think but it's that
it's that that preparation that uh that
growth that goal setting that these uh
these young men
have as they as they start uh looking
around and figuring out what they wanted
to do as as we talked earlier in the uh
in the podcast i really had you know
when i was in high school i didn't have
a clue what i wanted to do
when i got out of college if i was going
to be fortunate enough to get to college
and in today's environment it's
significantly different
our youngsters grow up seem to grow up a
lot faster
but that said they're not going to make
it through buds without that without
that background without that preparation
without those family values that's uh
that's so important they have to have
they have to have that base whether they
realize it or not they have that have to
have that base to succeed yeah and it's
so strange to to look at buds it
seems impossible to predict who's going
to make it and who's not uh
the
the amount of incredible athletes that
show up there and quit the you know i
know i had a guy
that was in my class that was a you know
ncaa water polo player had another guy
that was a gymnastics alternate on the
olympic gymnastics team and both those
guys quit
and you know i was like an average
maybe even a little below average
athlete in high school and
you know like i just was ready to just
stick it out
and what i was wanting to ask you
and i don't know how close you were to
it to see this but you know in talking i
remember talking to some of my friends
that worked as a physical therapist
right at buds
and i had a couple of them that had come
from uh professional sports and so in
professional sports
he was telling me you know he worked
with a baseball team or a football team
pro pro level teams and he'd say you
know i might see
one or two cases of patella femoral
syndrome
or
what is it itb swelling or this type of
back thing he goes i might see one or
two of those in a season
he goes i literally saw 48 cases of
patellofemoral syndrome in the last
three days it's like this highly
you just get this so much repetitive uh
you know injuries that happen to all
these guys coming in but then also what
the thing i was going to ask you about
is the
did you start to see any commonalities i
mean you kind of just mentioned but in
the like the psychological makeup of the
people because you got kids that come
from rich families that show up there
that were you know two parents that went
to church on sundays and the kids do
great you also see those same kids quit
you see some kid from the hood that grew
up without parents or you know a single
mom or a single dad and didn't have any
money didn't have anything and they make
it and you also see kids like that that
quit
what it looked like to you
i i agree with you 110
uh
you mentioned the uh the gymnast uh
we had a uh we had an olympic swimmer in
our in our class uh fred was a butterfly
guy fred made it
there was another ncaa swimmer in the
class
i believe his name well his name is not
important there was a ncaa swimmer in
the class
that uh that means you're like what the
top six or top eight in your uh in your
event in the country one of those
in any event uh uh this guy
busted his ass and one day in one of the
you know series of nuisance races
in the pool this kid beat
fred
in in one of the races
two days later kid's gone
his goal was to be able to say that he
beat this olympic swimmer
he was in there for the wrong reasons
i have never really been able to tell
you who was gonna make it it was not
uh but as i've as i've looked at it you
know for years and years and i've uh
worked with a guy by him of captain
bisset up in in new england as he uh
tries to prepare guys for training
he has
he has somewhere around a 70 better than
a 70
success rate for his candidates
uh
the average success rate of any class as
you know is somewhere around 25 or 30
percent graduate
in uh
in drew's case 75 graduate
so
as i've as i've looked at things over
the years there was another group when i
was a ceo of the center who had a 75
graduation rate
that group was a naval academy
candidates
let's stop and think about we're like
how many like how many of them were
naval academy
seven of the of the naval academy people
who came in oh i see so 75 of naval
academy guys make it right yep
let's stop and think about it in order
to get into the naval academy that is
one hell of a competitive process i
don't think the american public realizes
how competitive it is to get into a a
military service academy it you you know
it's either political appointment or
combination of political appointments
and uh exceptional uh academic
capability and uh and physical ability
uh for years those academies only gave
engineering degrees
uh i don't buy might be somewhere back
in the
in the 70s where they started with some
other degrees but it's very difficult to
get into the academies
so if you get into the academy you have
set a goal you have worked hard to
achieve that goal and you've attained
that goal
now in the case of the naval academy and
the uh
in the individuals who end up with a
quote of the buds uh
i'm not
an academy graduate i'm fairly sure of
how it works but if there's a guy out
there who wants to correct it please do
so
they have a a warfare specialty
selection process
and the number one guy in the class at
the naval academy can pick what warfare
specialty he wants to go to
uh
the uh the way it works
and that's the way it works whether he
decides he wants to be an aviator uh of
course if he wants to be a seal he's got
to pass the uh
the pft
uh but uh if he's got the uh the pft and
today he's got to go to uh soaz the
special ops uh
acquisition and selection
but
uh you've got to be at the top of your
class so you've you've not only fought
to get into the naval academy you have
fought to keep your uh your grades up
you have fought to keep your uh your
physical conditioning up because out of
the top hundred guys in the naval
academy they're probably going to eat up
those quotas to go to buds
and so
now there's 1100 guys in the naval
academy
every one of those 1100 individuals was
pretty outstanding to get there in the
first place now you've got to work to be
in the top 100 plus in the in that group
to get selected the buds so those guys
this is my reasoning those guys have
fought and challenged for every
everything that they have gotten every
step of the way
and so they're used to fighting and
they're used to overcoming adversity and
they're used to succeeding
so i give you that as a
that goal setting you know attain those
goals figure out where you want to go
set those girls early and and and drive
towards those goals
to your observation about the uh you
know patella syndrome yeah that was one
example i remember kids in my class got
this thing called patella femoral
syndrome or they got their it band was
this problem or they got this ankle
you know the my ankles rolled you know
the the the medics at buds will see
instead of being you know football
practice and in one season they see
whatever in a whole season they'll see
10 bad ankle sprints in buds they see
that every week every every week they
see that and they just
see these injuries over and over again
and i was just wondering from your
perspective what you saw
you know what was the reason
when someone says it why they quit
it's hard for me to comprehend
[Music]
that you enlist in the navy you know you
enlist in the navy when i enlisted the
navy i enlisted for six years in the
navy i'm freaking 18 years old i enlist
for six years of my life that's a what
is that a third of my life right i
enlist for a third of my life
i sign the dotted line i
i run and swim to get ready i go to boot
camp i put up with all that crap say
goodbye to my friends and families go
you know
tell everyone hey i'm gonna go try and
be a seal
get through boot camp
then finally show up to buds and like
the first day
after going through all that stuff
people are quitting
it's it's it's hard to comprehend did
you ever were you able to
put together any kind of
understanding of that
no uh and and uh i have i've gotten into
some uh conversations with people who
think that they've uh
come up with the uh with the test that's
going to show who's going to make it and
who's not
and uh
as far as i'm concerned they're full of
horse manure
let's go back to my observations about
those families of the of those
successful kids
they have
they have a sense of values um they uh
you know
whether they know uh right from wrong
the way we would want it to be uh that's
that's uh that's hard to say but they
have they have a sense of values that
they have grown up with uh and
and like the uh the naval academy
individuals that i've said these
individuals who succeed have set goals
and they they are very determined in
getting to those goals
and like i said to the uh to the family
we didn't
give them something that they didn't
have before they got here
and that's the thing that i don't know
about uh
i will tell you out loud that i never
thought about quitting in buds me
neither i puke you know uh yeah i i
cramped uh i used to you know i was the
worst runner in the class you know
everybody knows about getting a stitch
in your side when you're running i had a
goddamn freight train running through my
liver
and
i can't tell you how much it hurt but i
would actually say to myself to my to my
you know sniveling body
i would say is that all you got
the as you go through training it's all
between the ears you've got to have that
goal in mind and you've got to be
willing to put up with whatever it is
there's a couple of things i'm going to
say here
from the neck down is a life support
system for the neck up
the for the for the brain housing group
as we call it it's all between the ears
and and i don't know who said it first
but there's an expression that i use
about mind over matter
if you don't mind it don't matter
and and i i mean i can't tell you uh
again how how how much i i hurt on those
runs
as i as i look at you know so there's
there's something
either right or wrong with
with
with with a few thousand of our american
service members called seals uh that
have this that have this mindset there
is a there is definitely a mindset it's
not a killer mindset it's a success
mindset it's uh you know wolves and
sheep mindset you are what you are what
you are and i strongly believe that
there are people like that uh you know
my wife
my wife knows who i am and you know
don't
don't mess with me you know uh
so
uh and and that's the way it is with
with with every seal i know yet you
don't mess with the guy and it's not
just because of my size or jocko's size
it's because of the attitude you're
gonna lose
uh you know uh instructor moy one day uh
i'm on the i'm in the goon squad i've uh
i've uh i maintain for those of us that
are old enough to remember there used to
be a half a dozen pi or a half a dozen
palm trees uh out in front of the hotel
dell that go down to the uh go down to
the rocks where we do our rock portage
i maintain that i that that i have
probably caused the death of at least
one of those palm trees because i ended
up puking at the bottom of those because
of what the what those guys made me do
in the in the goon squad
it didn't matter i didn't give a good
goddamn what they did to me they could
not get that four-letter word out of me
quit it was not gonna happen
i was i was we were down there by the
rocks and i'd done the uh i've done the
roll in the surf the roll and this in
the uh and the soft dry sand we used to
call them sugar cookies because now here
i am uh i'm coated in water and uh and
and white sparkling sand from the
coronado silver strand and i'm doing
what's called the duck walk so you're
you're squatting down and you've got
your hand full hands folded behind your
head
and i will admit that i was not doing
the duck walk without with any uh degree
of alacrity shall we say
was i feeling sorry for myself you bet
your ass
and instructor moy comes up to me and he
you know like i say i'm squatting down
with my hands behind my head you know
trying to squat waddle walk whatever
towards the uh
towards the ocean
and moy is roaring at me says what the
hell are you giving it there instant
richards
and i looked up at him and i said would
you call would you believe a sick duck
and and i watched i watched chief moy
have to turn around
his shoulders are shaking but
i was not i was not quitting and and and
there's that there's that something
that uh all these psychiatrists
psychologists whatever they are they
haven't quite been able to figure out
what it is
again i keep going back to the goal
setting go back today's training
young men young men not only have to
train in order to be able to pass the uh
past the pft uh you know if if they uh
if they if they only do the run in 12
and a half minutes they ain't gonna make
it through buds
and that's for a couple of reasons it's
not only because of the physical ability
per se to do the run but it's what i
look at as the ability to recover
because when you get to buds if you
haven't been doing this for years
and years
you know if you haven't been running if
you haven't been swimming
you haven't gotten if you haven't been
doing that for years
you
are going to break down when you get the
buds so you have to really have built up
your ability to recover
okay i didn't do a lot of swimming and i
didn't do a lot of running in
preparation for buds but i was lifting
weights at that time at pretty close to
a damn pro level and i was doing it 12
and a half 13 months a year
uh that's what i that's what i lived to
do i was
when i got the buds i could do pt all
day long if i only had to do push-ups
with my own body weight that was a whole
lot of doing repping out with 315 pounds
ah well gotta do a few push-ups oh
that's okay
i i i i'm joking about that but push-ups
didn't bother me
and to uh to uh to the uh to the olympic
swimmer we had in our class you know
fred was probably on vacation during
those swims and he probably fell asleep
on the six mile swim out at the you know
san clemente island
but
that gave fred a chance to recover
when when i was doing pt you know the pt
circle in the morning okay
i knew that i unless unless some
instructor got really innovative i
probably wasn't going to have too much
trouble with this
and so if you've got something like the
swim or you're an incredible runner and
you can keep up with those instructors
you know through the soft sand runs and
not only is it not difficult for you
physically but because it's not
difficult for you physically it's an
emotional break you know there's a
certain amount of mental stress or
mental strength that you don't have to
use during that particular evolution so
if you're in really good shape that
takes a strain a stress factor out of a
particular event run swim
uh you know whatever whatever it might
be
but even with that ability uh you know
we had a we had a high school or a
junior college uh miler who did a damn
mile in something like four minutes and
10 or 15 seconds you know you clocked me
with a damn calendar
this
this this guy quit
you know
uh
but
you know you you take off the cute
little nylon running shorts and you put
on the the cami pants and uh the boots
and all of a sudden it's a different
kind of running but
all that said there has to be that mind
that mindset there and in addition to
that that physical capability there's
got to be that mindset what it is i i
don't know every once in a while you run
into a guy
i have a uh
a classmate of mine i'm not going to
mention his name because
somebody's still on active duty but uh
years ago one of his sons was expressing
uh
interest in the in the teams
and
that particular
individual did did not get get to the
teams uh he didn't get to uh to training
for whatever reason it was but we had
gone down and we had spent some time
with
my classmate
and as i'm driving back with uh with
jackie
i said to jack he said sweetheart
schmuckatelli is going to be the the
member of that family that makes it
through there's just that feeling i got
from that kid
and yes he did
and every once in a while yeah you get
that
but but not often it was it was his
demeanor it was his presence uh it was
his uh
his confidence not cocky but but but his
confidence you can't always see that uh
and and i was probably lucky in that uh
in in that judgment uh but uh he uh
he made it uh yeah proud of him uh but
to your point uh jocko
i i don't know what the it factor is and
i look at the the confidence in the and
the goal setting
and the and the ability to recover to
get you through uh as you as you heard i
like to think if an individual's got a
uh
got a specialty where he can uh you know
take a break uh uh that that that will
be very helpful to him
but uh there's just there's some
missing link there that uh that i don't
i don't know exactly what it is and it's
just so hard to put your finger on
did you notice anything
from from when you went through in 1969
1970
and and then you fast forward what 20
something years
was there anything that you said oh they
got soft over here they got weak over
here this is easier or this is harder
i'm gonna say it got harder
and uh
so i take over as the ceo of the uh of
the center and uh
one of the things that i did was i i
looked at uh this the schedules for
the uh
each of the different phases uh
and i i also looked at you know all the
schedules for the advanced training
because one of the things i wanted to do
is i wanted to go out
and and observe uh you know observe the
class observe the instructors
i went and i spent time out at san
clemente island when i was the uh the
commanding officer uh yeah i went to uh
to wherever there was uh wherever there
was training
uh
so
i take over as a skipper and i'm looking
at the the training schedules now
when i went through training
i do not recall
a training day that started
before zero 700.
we had to be on the line at zero 700.
and i was after breakfast so we didn't
you know form up uh but training started
at zero 700.
and uh
i uh
got to training
and i'm looking at the i'm looking at
the schedule the zero four hundred zero
four hundred zero four hundred zero five
when i went through it was early
and this particular thing that uh jumped
out of me was a zero five thirty or zero
five fifty or a zero five fifteen
four mile time run
and i'm saying
what the hell is this [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you know
i was saying that too i was doing them
so uh
whether it was the first phase of the
second phase you know they came up to me
and
i said you know
what are we doing here well that's the
uh
that's the uh the only uh only low tide
and
that guy
is one of the luckiest guys in naval
special warfare
because my question was how [ __ ]
stupid do i look
[Laughter]
one high tide in the morning one low
tide in the morning one high in the
afternoon one low in the afternoon
and uh that that is not cast in stone
because there are a certain number of
days in the year uh where you only have
uh you know a combination of three tides
you know you know you'll get two highs
i said
do not
even think about
opening your mouth to say anything else
about the tides
but to my point
they were they they were now doing uh
four mile time runs and maybe an old
course or uh another session before
breakfast
and uh like i say we we didn't do that
now when we uh when we were out at san
clemente island
there was no schedule was 24 hours a day
yeah uh but uh uh other otherwise uh you
know of course there were there were
night swims uh you know of course when
you get uh it wasn't like uh you know
seven to five every day yeah you you
might have uh
uh
you know at night uh you know night
navigation or we'd uh we'd go up to
different places for uh orienteering and
so on and again you you throw the clock
out the window just because of uh
because of what you're doing but uh
basically
uh
when we were at the strand it was a uh
it was a seven to five or seven to five
thirty or again you talk about night
dives and so on of course you're you're
working until uh you know 10 11 midnight
whatever it might be
so uh so it it has changed they they are
putting uh at least uh 12 or 15 pounds
into a 10 pound bag
i mean they are really
they're they're using every every every
minute of the day
so if somebody asks me is training hard
at the day you bet your ass it is
and the gut the kids are in better shape
they're all
they're all in better shape so like if
you're running with your boat crew
you're you're running with guys that are
able to run faster so you better better
be able to run faster they're just all
in better shape i was over there a
couple years ago and one of my buddies
was now a civilian working there
and we were having the same conversation
and we were standing out by the first
phase office and he you know there's a
hundred helmets lined up
and
and he said you know he goes look at
these hundred whatever it was 122
helmets he goes every one of these guys
i'm telling you was a stud
and they're gone
it's like this program is hard i said
yeah roger that it's a heartbreaking
program it is and and as he said every
one of those 120 guys was a stud
and and it goes to that
that missing factor in there what is
that you know what is it that caused
you
to put up with all that crap
you know why did you do that some some
of it is you know uh just person here
perseverance you know bullheadedness and
so on but there's there's some other
factor in there
yeah we wanted to uh you know wanted to
do something for uh for our country uh
we wanted to do the best job that we
could we want to do and as a result we
selected what we thought was the uh the
hardest i didn't realize that when i did
that you know you know 50 years ago that
wasn't that it
it wasn't known that way uh but i i i
knew that it was going to be hard and i
selected it anyway in today's day
environment uh every one of these kids
knows it's going to be a ball buster
it's going to be hard
uh and and yet they yet they select that
there's there's a missing factor why
those young americans decide to do that
i can't i can't put my finger on all
that and there's that missing factor
about
what it is
that enables these individuals to put up
with what is arguably the most difficult
training you know in in the military in
the world
did you
think you were going to become an
admiral
never
[Laughter]
at that what number seal admiral were
you
number five
so had been there had been four prior to
you
how'd that go down
how that how'd that how did you hear
about that
about the fact that uh about all the
above i guess well i mean you must have
been thinking hey all right i'm gonna
get done with this tour i'll be a
captain i'm gonna retire because well i
uh
jocko i i i will not ever claim to have
been the sharpest tool in the shed
but it was probably one of the hardest
working [ __ ] in the in the
building
uh
i took one particular job uh you know
from a friend of mine
and i remember him saying yeah your
first couple of weeks three weeks you
know you might be here til 5 5 30 6
o'clock or something like that but after
that you can get it down you'll be out
of here at 4 30 every day
well
i never left at 4 30 in the entire two
years that i had the job
uh
and uh it was like i said i worked as
hard as i could in whatever job it was
and the other thing that i will say is i
think you really have to be
who you are
somewhere around 7 24.
uh
when i was selected to flag officer uh
admiral lemoine chuck lemoine was the
navy seal on the board
there were
a number of guys a year or two senior to
me
um that i had a
high expectation that you know tom
dicker harry was going to be uh uh you
know selected during that period of time
but that was my uh you know basically my
first time up uh you have to have uh
completed your uh
major command tour uh you know to uh to
be eligible and then you got you got
three looks
but uh so anyway chuck was on the on the
board
and i had worked for uh for admiral
lemoyne uh when uh
he was a
group one commander
and
as i said you have to be who you are
7 24.
well when i was working for chuck uh
i was the uh
i was the first relatively senior
officer uh in the building uh
uh in in the day uh you know i usually
beat the chief of staff in i usually
beat the uh
uh beat the commodore in all the time uh
because you know
our job was to prepare the uh prepare
the environment before he showed up
uh and so anyway uh
there was a there was an individual in
the organization who was who was up for
captain and didn't get selected
and uh because i was there
and it was out here on the west coast
uh you remember margaret
indeed margaret the detailer uh great
great lady she uh she did she did well
by me uh more than one occasion but um
me too
anyway uh margaret uh
margaret called out uh asking for the
chief of staff he wasn't there how about
the commodore he's not there he said
well here's the deal you know so and so
didn't uh the uh the 06 list is uh is
coming out and uh you know you know
schmuckatelli is not on it
and we wanted to give lemoyne the chance
to uh
uh to prep them before uh
before
everybody else saw that and uh
so that he'd be
prepared for any bad news
so
uh admiral lemoyne gets uh again captain
at the time um gets in uh
10 or 15 minutes before the uh morning
uh you know meeting at eight o'clock
and
by uh by a habit or custom uh he didn't
like to be interrupted before the uh
before the meeting he uh he wanted to
prepare himself as well
so i bang on the door and barge on in
and i said excuse me captain uh you need
to hear this uh and uh so i shared the
uh shared the news and uh left the
office
so uh it was it was my job to uh to herd
the cats and get everybody into the uh
to the briefing room in the morning
and uh there are a few of us standing in
the in the hallway
smoking and joking as you usually do uh
yeah getting ready to go in and sit uh
sit in a meeting that uh you know be 60
minutes of your life that you'll never
regain
so
we uh we're smoking and joking and uh
captain one comes down the passageway
and uh
he uh he made a uh observation as i
guess i can imagine what you're talking
about
uh and uh
my take on that was he thought i might
have shared the situation with the
guy who did not get selected uh and i i
turned to the attorney cabinet
no cabin where uh that's that's that's
not on the agenda it's not uh anything
that i felt that uh was uh in my purview
to share with anybody
and it's things like that
when
you're dealing with you know junior
officers and senior officers that that
leave an impression i think i i think i
left that impression on
on captain lemoine so when uh several
years later he's uh he's on the on the
flag board uh he had some personal
experience with uh who i was and what my
values were
and so that's
that's kind of how how that that works i
believe uh you got to work hard uh you
gotta you gotta do well you can't do
some you know some some stupid things
but uh i have to tell you that
i just wanted to do as good a job as i
could
and take care of all the people working
for me that i could
uh and uh and and i think it paid off uh
people like uh alma worthington and uh
yeah i'm a lemoyne uh i'm sure that the
two of them uh had a had a conversation
about uh you know who was gonna who's
gonna get selected so
yeah and i mean
at that time there just wasn't that many
seal admirals so no uh you had uh
no there there absolutely weren't uh and
uh i guess not worthy to probably smith
i think worthington was retired by then
but uh
uh you know uh
you i mean you just gotta be who you are
724 and
you know working harder than everybody
else helps
being there uh when it counts
i said that i might have said that there
was a short list when i raised my hand
to uh go to el salvador
uh
they only needed one line on the list uh
there were you know there were no other
volunteers
at that point in time uh and and and the
leadership of the community uh you know
recognizes those things
and
the last the last place tom richards
wanted to go after being ceo seal team
one was the naval sea systems command
and sit at a desk and and do procurement
and research and development i couldn't
even spell it if it hadn't been for
tommy hawkins the community would have
been in deep kimchi
oh boy
so you end up going taking over what we
call naval special warfare command which
means you're in charge of all the seals
all the special boat units
all in charge of basic seal training
advanced filter you're in charge of
everything
and that was
that that had to be a pretty
a pretty climactic moment for you to
take command
oh jocko uh
that was uh that was an incredible
opportunity uh and and an incredible
honor to uh uh to be selected to uh to
have that job uh to lead a community
like naval special warfare uh
not everybody who gets selected the flag
gets the opportunity for that job
uh
and uh i i am thankful to the
leadership of our community you know
again abel lemoine uh for uh for giving
me admiral moin and admiral smith for
giving me that uh that opportunity
uh and uh
those were some of my uh most most
rewarding years no
we were still in our if you will early
years with special operations command
we were still in our early years
of uh
somewhat of a divorce from the navy
if you will because uh you know
my uh i had uh had two two people i uh
reported to you know one was a uh a
joint service commander army navy air
force or marine uh down there in tampa
and uh the other was a a code up on the
uh the op nav staff you know ultimately
of course to the cno
but uh
the uh the money was
there's there's something called the
golden rule he what's got the gold rules
and uh
the uh the the money at that time was
from socom uh and uh that's where you
know the vast majority of my uh my
attention went
but uh
going back to the uh to the
opportunities uh there were so many
things uh so many things going on in the
uh in the world uh
uh and and specifically within our
community
uh
there was a uh
captain by the name of uh todd visey he
was not a captain at the time but todd
was uh stationed down at uh navy
military personnel command
after i believe that was after they had
uh it was after they had shifted down to
uh to memphis
and
what todd did was he carried the water
for
our efforts
to create
the swic community
uh you know when i uh when i took over
as ceo of special boat unit 13
we had
fleet sailors coming to drive these
small boats
the engines the uh you know quote main
propulsion engines of a uh
65 foot mark iii patrol boat where a
detroit v detroit diesel
8v
71 ti
uh i think uh and uh it was a long time
ago but
that engine was usually
if they saw it on a ship
that might be an auxiliary diesel
generator
not the main propulsion engine they
might not have ever seen it so you get a
an engine from the fleet who's never
seen your engine uh you get a gunner's
mate from his fleet who's looking for
the five-inch gun
uh you get a uh you get a communications
or electronics technician who's looking
for uh you know
cic
it ain't there uh and oh by the way uh
you need to learn about the m60 the
prick 77. um yeah you you name it that
they've never seen before in their life
so
we get these guys for two or three years
they learn a lot about naval special
warfare then boom they're gone
i took over as uh ceo of the center
and uh we had continuing conversations
with the then current
ceos of the special boat units they were
called units then not teams
and
they decided that they wanted the center
to host a uh a training program
for their uh for their fleet guys coming
in
we were still losing them after three
years
but they wanted to instead of having to
learn all this uh on the job let's let's
put it together and teach them about
this
special warfare stuff that they're now
in the middle of
so we started out the first class with a
three and a half week class
and when we laid it out as a three and a
half week class
they were concerned
that that was too much time uh you know
to have these guys away from the team
now of course because they're away from
the team that means that they had a boat
or two that was not manned
so understand that
they finished up with the class
the skippers were so charged
that
the next class was a five-week class
that they they decide
and that all grew so i go from
co special unit 13
with the problem
trying to solve part of it as the as a
commanding officer of the center and now
when i get to the uh to be the commander
of naval special warfare
i was able to
convince the navy to create the swick
nec
and uh that was just uh
yeah that was
just i think a a great accomplishment
for the community and i have to look at
folks like todd veazey and congratulate
them and thank them for their work
and there was a uh
there was a boat guy master chief uh
kelly webb uh unfortunately kelly has
since passed uh but kelly was a uh was a
big prime mover in that as well and i
will also say that uh at one point in
time when i was looking for the uh for
the next uh you know command uh or the
force master chief for naval special
warfare it came down to kelly in a uh
and a trident winner
so those are the last two guys standing
uh but he was uh he was quite a guy so
the establishment of the uh the swick
swift community was something that was
uh
uh just uh just outstanding and it's now
it's a rate and everything and guys go
in that's their career they can go and
have their whole career in special
special boat team
and one of the you know
it it's
i remember having a
get-together i i
i
talked to
as many folks as i could on each coast
and uh i remember you know saying to
folks i said guys you know this is this
is this is hard for me because
so much of my time
is going to be directed upward you know
whether it's you know
budget personnel matters that that i'm
going to have to work with so calm in
the in the navy uh when i walked in and
took command at uh at naval special
warfare
there was a
relatively new building
that didn't come close to accommodating
the staff at naval special warfare
command when i walked in
uh six eight ten maybe use twenty
trailers
surrounding the building you know and i
don't want to offend anybody but i i
referred to
naval special warfare command's facility
as trailer park trash
and uh you know here we are this you
know you know sitting right next to the
uh uh to those uh those
gorgeous multi-million dollar
condominiums they're looking down on a
trailer park i'm sure they love that
so the first budget cycle that i went
into
with uh with the uh four star commander
down there in the in tampa
and and i you know stood up and i
pounded the table and i said
look at this building you guys got you
know look at the addition you're putting
on i said yeah i walked in and i've got
i've got my people working in trailers
in trailers
and uh long story short because it's the
way things work
we got that much we got an accelerated
military construction program that you
know clearly wasn't done by the time i
uh i left command but
that was that became one of the top
priorities for the socom socom milcon
budget to uh to get us some buildings
and i'll go one step further uh you know
this afternoon i'm getting a chance to
go down and uh and and view uh
uh the new uh new facilities for uh for
seal team one
that whole naval special warfare complex
down there
is
billions of dollars
more importantly
that says
that that billion-dollar figure
was high enough on the priority list to
get funded that says that socom and the
united states navy and the department of
defense
recognized the commitment required to
retain the capability that naval special
warfare provides to our military
readiness
they understand that and they're funding
it it's not just a bunch of new
buildings it says so much more than that
yeah that that is
so impressive what's down there what
they built for and it's all the all the
west coast seal team down there it's
it's absolutely
phenomenal it's like i mean i remember
when i got to seal team one and checked
in
it was very underwhelming i mean we we
kind of i guess our building i don't
know what year that building was built
where seal team one was but it was maybe
10 years old maybe 15 years old
something i'll tell you when it was
built because it was it was turned over
to me as the ceo of seal team one in
1986 so the building was five or six
years old i guess when i got there in
1991
and
i mean all it was was pretty much like a
little office building had some had some
lockers in it but it was it was
underwhelming you know the gym where i
worked out with you was just you know is
this a normal gym looked like somebody
threw together whatever random equipment
um i think we had we had two squat racks
i mean it was just kind of hodgepodge
and you didn't expect that you know it
was the whole and the whole thing kind
of felt hodgepodge i guess is what i'm
saying
you go now now check out that facility
you're gonna be it's like a it's like
the james bond movie you know the james
bond movie where they're training
commandos somewhere and they open up a
door and there's people rappelling down
there's pools and all this shooting
ranges that's what it's like it's it's
it's phenomenal that that the nation has
made that a priority to to put these
guys in the right spot
a few years ago i had the chance to go
up to uh go up to alaska and uh we've
got a training facility up there in
alaska and i was stunned to see the
improvements that have been made to that
uh to that training facility uh to
include a god it must be a 50 or 60 foot
climbing wall in there just uh just
absolutely amazing and again those those
improvements you know
not only speak to the readiness but also
speak to the recognition of the uh of
the leadership of our of our military
with the importance of the special
operations community and it's just such
a great way to support those those guys
you know the last thing i did before i
retired was run the training on the west
coast for guys getting ready to deploy
and
just there's nothing more important than
making sure that guys are ready to go do
that job absolutely
uh you know speaking of your trip down
to seal team one
uh
you're doing that this afternoon we're
probably a little over three hours right
now
what did you do what'd you do once you
retired
uh i got the uh i got the chance to work
for a uh
a boat company uh up in
up in new hampshire and i i work for a
uh a gentleman who's uh you know
probably uh
uh
probably not much shy of uh you know a
uh uh
a genius uh
we uh
uh we developed a boat uh called the uh
uh called the ghost
and uh you know greg sankoff is the
gentleman's name uh and so many
innovative things that he put into this
uh and i'm you know navy's just not uh
just not ready for that craft perhaps
yet and of course there's a few other
challenges to get it in to fit and
be interoperable with uh with uh the
systems that we have available today but
uh that was a that was a fun experience
i had the chance to take what i had
learned as the uh
as a naval special warfare program
officer at nav c
uh and and of course knowing what i knew
about the the requirements of
of naval special warfare and you know
what some of the things they could do
that was a that was a a real fun job
and i and i also worked for a uh for an
alaskan native company
uh
alaskan native companies uh
are uh
minority owned and uh and operated by
alaskan natives uh
we have uh we have other uh you know
small business uh set aside uh you know
there's uh uh are there uh
also uh uh
set asides for the uh you know black uh
hispanic community
uh i i'm not sure but in in any american
indians
uh
so they had special uh
contractual uh
advantages if you will
uh and
what i saw
uh whether it was for the uh alaskan
natives native americans uh
these folks would take those advantages
and do a good job whatever it was it was
uh uh requested or required and in the
in the contracting world defense the
defense department contracting world
there is a requirement for major
contractors to have a percentage of
minority contracts
one of the neatest things that i saw
about this company uh and and and the
company's name is uh
elutic and a fognac is the apparent
company but
the
the programs that they had for the
development of
their uh
of their tribal members
were were absolutely amazing uh
carl who ran the computer uh side of uh
of things was
uh
absolutely amazing uh he uh
he was a uh he's
a native
who you know went to school on
scholarship programs you know you know
college masters and so on and uh he just
had such a impressive computer system
for the for the entire company and i say
that because i've never worked anywhere
else it was anywheres near as good if
you hear this one carl
you owe me a beer uh but uh just and
carl was one and there uh there were a
couple of a couple of young ladies in
the uh in the in the company uh who were
uh uh just you know
uh a pleasure to work with uh when you
saw uh
that they were if you will a product of
the system and and and it proved what a
good job that they were doing uh you
know they whether it was a college or a
vocational technical training uh they
had all kinds of programs set up for uh
for their folks it wasn't you know you
know uh you know
five or ten thousand bucks every uh
every uh six months or a year or
whatever it was they had all these great
programs set up and
and uh they uh they would take those uh
take those funds uh and take the profits
and build a fund and so on i was i was
pretty impressed with uh with how they
did it and and i only say this much
about it is because of you know some of
the uh bad press that some of uh uh that
people have given it and how uh how it
was non-competitive etc you know there
was a lot of competition among those
those alaskan native uh you know
companies uh uh and uh and they and they
they did a damn good job uh so it's
quite an impressive program and again an
opportunity to learn uh you know so much
about uh the alaskan natives it's just
uh uh
great opportunity
their base
uh is
on kodiak island where our training
facility is uh their their corporate
headquarters their real business offices
are in anchorage
so i get to start meeting a number of
the you know the natives you know
all the board members were uh were were
natives and many of them had spent a lot
of time on kodiak where we have our
training facility
and then they learned that i'm a retired
seal and they tell me about the time
those god damn seals you know walked
across these uh uh
uh uh you know special uh you know
sacred uh you know burial grounds or
areas that were set aside and they
weren't supposed to be
but
i believe those fences uh fences are
mended not not due to anything that i
did
but there are a couple of uh a couple of
folks who have
whatever uh acreage they have on either
a fog neck or uh kodiak
and and they allow the the seals to as
they're conducting some of their
missions up there uh to use some of that
property to touch base and use the
staging points and that kind of thing so
uh it was really fun for me to see that
relationship a couple of years ago when
i went up to uh to alaska where were you
when september 11th happened
i was uh
i was driving in my truck i was working
for saic at the time
and i was coming up from uh from
virginia beach
headed to uh headed to dc
and uh my wife was uh
my wife was uh up uh you know working uh
in uh indeed in uh vienna
with uh with a friend of hers and uh
so i'm in my truck and i hear this and i
called jackie i said
get a tank of gas
and when you can get out of there get
out of there
uh
when i heard it and by time i had a
chance to get older
it was too late
so i was headed on into saic
and i knew that whatever had been uh
uh you know i forget exactly what i was
going up there for
but i knew that that was out the window
and i said to myself
i was i think i was about
fredericksburg
when i heard it i said well
if i keep coming north
i'm not going to be home for
a long time
and i just just knew that and uh
they took uh a few of us with military
experience
and we set up a uh a talk and we set up
uh you know started setting up phone
trees trying to find uh
find out who was where and how everybody
was and so it was uh
it was quite a quite an interesting
experience from
that side of things
and then what did it look like to you as
you watched the the seal teams
start to engage in the in the war on
terror
so
uh
shortly after that
my wife and i are sitting at home
watching a news show
and they're showing something about the
northern alliance doing this and their
thing and they showed two
big open back trucks we'd call them a
four by four or rather a six buy or
something like that
and uh
i looked at the uh i looked at the video
and i said to jackie said sweetheart
that truck is filled with afghans
that truck is our guys
well how can you tell
i say i can tell by the way they sit i
can tell by their posture and i can tell
by the way they hold their weapons
look at the differences so
and
i knew i knew right then it was going to
be you know quite a uh quite a deal
uh
because of the work i was doing with uh
saic i had the opportunity to sit in on
a briefing that was uh given by the
chief of naval operations at the time
and he had been with the president just
a few days before
and as he uh recounted his uh
experience with the uh with the
president you
could have heard a pin drop in the room
given the the commitment
uh and the
will
to
fix that
and
i guess what are you up to right now
you retired yet for real uh i'm i'm
retired for real uh before i leave i'll
give you a business card that says
leadership management and motivation but
uh
uh uh i work with a few kids every once
in a while who've got a desire to go to
buds uh but uh yeah jackie and i are
supporting a uh a wildlife museum in in
virginia beach and uh other than that
we're uh we're pretty much uh pretty
much retired but uh
anybody wants a an old fart with an
opinion uh you know
give me a call
well like i said i know you got another
appointment this afternoon uh going to
check out the teams uh
probably a good place to wrap up echo
you got any questions yes all right here
we go we still lifting weights or what
well
given the uh seven plus decades i've
been on the face of the earth
uh the uh yeah you know few and uh few
and far between i've uh i've actually uh
just in the last five or six weeks uh
started to uh to to go back in the gym
uh but uh it's something i'll never stop
uh and and the reason for it is you know
at uh at 74 years of age i don't have to
hire somebody to cut my lawn i can still
go out there i can do it
uh you know i don't have to i have to
hire somebody to move those boxes around
the house i don't have to hire somebody
to move that dresser uh you know i can i
can still do that
and that's
that's not only speaking to my physical
well-being it's speaking to my medical
well-being and she's my mental
well-being just be able to do that yeah
you've got a gym at your house
uh i've got a few hundred pounds
so here you go
when i went down to el salvador i went
unaccompanied for a year
and uh with that i was able to send
a thousand pounds or 1100 pounds of
personal gear
700 pounds of weightlifting equipment
i had i had
squat racks a bench and at least 500
pounds of pounds of weights in my own
room
in my own my own building uh
when i uh
there was a
the guy i uh i relieved was assassinated
uh but they actually had a goals in el
salvador
so i said well
i'll give that a shot and so i i went to
goals a few times and
i'm dead lifting five and a half or
whatever
and uh not drawing any attention to
yourself
yeah
you're right stupid with a capital s
and uh i ended up getting
i found out from a certain intelligence
agency that uh my nickname in the gym
was el grua which stands for the crane
uh and
and uh
next thing i i hear the colonel i
mentioned before calls me into the
office and he said
we got a report that uh there's some
folks taking notice of your attendance
of goals i said ah [ __ ] and so that was
the last time i went to goals
oh man but
well look we we got a bunch of stories
out of you today uh like i said i know
you got to go um
you got any closing thoughts you want to
say
uh
i had a great 30 years
a lot of good guys
and i'll tell you
one one important closing thought
when i took over in 96
we were still deploying seal platoons
the same way same way i walked out the
door in 1970
26 years a lot of things changed in
those 26 years
uh captain pete tonys and stan
damn it
both guys had been
group commanders on the east coast had
come in and had pitched a uh
pitched a uh
recommended change of how to do business
uh and we were calling it the squadron
deployment
so what i did at that point in time is i
sat down with uh uh with admiral smith
who was still uh still on active duty uh
and uh admiral eric olsen
and a couple of other folks and i said
guys
this is what i think we want to do
uh you may not be aware but in the uh
8485 time frame we had tried something
like that with style with seal team one
and it didn't work won't go into those
details but i sat down with admiral
smith admiral olsen because i knew i
knew eric was going to be following well
maybe it didn't by that point in time
but my goal was to make sure eric was
going to be the next flag officer
anyhow
good judgment on my part by the way
better better work by eric uh but i sat
down with those guys i said guys this is
what i this is what i think we should do
now i don't know exactly what it's going
to look like
but so what i did is i i went after
talking to those guys i went back
and we set up a uh set up a working
group on the on the war com staff
and the senior guy in the working group
was probably a commander
and i said guys
the last thing
i ever want to hear is
the admiral said or the admiral wants
other than the fact that i want to
figure out how to make this work
i think we i think we need to change how
we're doing business we had
oh fours
down to e6s
on that uh on that working group to
figure out how to make it work
and uh
we uh we didn't get it we didn't get it
fielded by the time i uh by the time i
left uh command uh but we had the uh
we had the core of of what we were
looking at we were already already
looking at uh you know different uh team
deployments and how we were going to
change that all so we'd have one team uh
with uh boat guys intelligence support
logistics support that kind of thing uh
deploying forward and uh as i as i
stopped and
looked today uh it looks a whole lot
different than uh than what what walked
out the door finally under eric olsen
but i am i am so proud of stan and pete
uh of uh bringing that to me and uh us
us taking that and laying the groundwork
because this is now
uh this is now 22
going on 23 years after we started
working on that and here naval special
warfare with you know lipstick on the uh
on the pig in a certain number of places
but it's it's still the same pig uh and
uh
or it's the uh probably it's probably a
borehog by now
uh but it's uh it's it's what we uh it's
what we started framing at that point in
time as the as a way for naval special
warfare uh to do business and uh and
again i'm proud of that working group
proud of pete and stan uh and uh the
other guys agreeing because
i didn't like i said i didn't want to
start going down this road if somebody
was gonna you know throw out you know
dozens of man years of work and planning
to uh to toss it out so that was uh
that in in in combination with uh the uh
the swic nec
uh where
the the two things that uh that i
figured were probably the uh you know
best accomplishments that uh uh that i
that i ever had
let me add one more thing you talked
earlier about uh
working with the
uh the physical therapist and so on uh
you need to uh to go back and thank uh
uh i believe it was pete tony's uh who
who started that uh you know bringing in
those uh those physical therapists uh to
work with the uh with the with the team
guys uh but there's you know it's it's
it's interesting for me to hear your
comments on how important those kinds of
things are
work to you in your career and i think
you know
way to go there pete you know those guys
were those guys were doing some uh some
good things so but those are the uh
those are the two biggest things that uh
that i'm probably proudest of uh
that that and uh and petty officer uh
bacchus coming up to me at seal team one
that's outstanding and and that
transition that you started that you
initiated uh that got pushed to you i
guess up through the chain of command to
to redo the way we were deploying i mean
the the way the deployments went
eventually once the war started
we would have been just kind of
worthless you know being a random
platoon out there by yourself you just
you just don't have the value that you
need to bring to the battlefield and and
what we were able to do as giant
squadrons with all the augmentees with
all the logistical support that's
what we needed and and look didn't mean
we lost our ability to be nimble because
we could still take a platoon from that
squadron and kick them out to some
random out station you could have a five
or six man element i had i had little
elements sitting in tiny spots out on
their own and but we were able to do
that because of that that squadron
idea came to fruition and otherwise we
wouldn't have been able to been
functional
one other thing contributed to the
success of that squadron uh
when you first came in the teams where
uh were platoons still deploying on em
fibs yep i did two amphib deployments
myself and so i did one my first
deployment was to guam and then i did
back-to-back art platoons
out here in san diego six months on the
ship
well
being able to take
the platoons off the arg was another key
part of that
and i can remember going to
cincus nav eur
four-star admiral
saying this is what i want to do and
this is how i want to do it
and uh
that is
when the amphibs try to do advanced
force ops that means you got to get
those amphibious ships within a few
miles of the coast you're not doing
anything advanced force
uh and one of the terms that they wanna
that they use is doing in stride
amphibious operations so they can just
drive up to the beach and do their thing
but
if you have to stop and let the seals do
their thing yeah you're sitting there
with a uh with a bull's eye on you so
i had to be
somewhat tactful with circus navier uh
yeah because no no leaders ever want to
give up their assets they don't want to
give them up nope they they did not uh
and so i explained to him how a
submarine and explained to him uh you
know
jim was a uh
jim was a you know commanding officer of
a nuclear aircraft carrier probably not
much i have to explain to him
but as
as i laid it out to him i said you know
we you know we have these uh
theater special operations commands and
these forces allocated to them they're
not only navy special warfare they're
army and air force assets that are
available to you there and you can get
there by submarine you can get there by
c-130 you can get rubber ducks there are
no c-130s on the mfibs that i've that
i've seen uh et cetera et cetera and he
said well well who's gonna who's gonna
pay for that uh you know the uh i said
we are naval special warfare and u.s
special operations command he said sold
and uh that's that's how we uh that's
that's the third biggest thing that i
feel that uh
that i can uh yeah hang my hat on in in
my career uh you know getting getting
people to finally understand if you want
to do something in stride for the mfibs
you're probably going to launch that uh
that reconnaissance from somewhere else
as it should be yeah
well
outstanding outstanding stuff uh
i'm the open invite anytime you come
back if you listen this and there's
other things you want to talk about that
you missed uh scratch them down on a
piece of paper this this place is yours
uh it's been an honor to sit down and
talk with you
um you know obviously thanks for
everything that you did for the country
for the teams
for the navy
um and thanks for putting some faith in
a e4 that came to your office wanting to
request and you you legitimately changed
the trajectory of my life and and
that's how i ended up here so it's been
an honor and thank you thank you jocko
and i don't know if you knew it but uh
for the first two or three years that
they had that semen the admiral program
and i guess you were in like the second
year
naval special warfare you and the other
boys who went in there uh you guys were
the top
four
candidates each year
we're just trying to hold up the line
good job thanks sir appreciate it
all right
the hulk
has departed the area of operations
the
it's just freaking crazy
to sit here kind of like it was crazy
with with
mike durant yeah when i was watching him
on tv after he'd been captured in
somalia and i was watching him in 1993
as a young seal new guy and now we're
sitting here talking to him think of how
crazy this is here i am talking to
admiral richards who literally wrote the
recommendation for me to become a seal
officer
in
19 what was that
30 years ago 25 years ago something like
this yeah
and
he's
legendary seal
from seal team one where i'm from he was
the commanding officer of seal team one
right before i showed up he was he was
the commanding officer of buzz by the
way when i graduated
and here he is just right there
debriefing
i'll tell you what's awesome and i was
talking to him about this a little bit
i was telling him that when mike
thornton came on the podcast
and
i had i forget when mike thornton
actually retired but we overlapped in
time you know i was in for a while while
he was in
not very long because he retired
probably somewhere around when i came in
i don't know but but there was overlap
time there was time he was in the teams
he was a seal team one guy he was a
medal of honor recipient
legendary
legendary like you need to put music
behind that when i say it on the like in
post
so so mike thornton
but as much as i knew
who mike thornton was i had met him you
know i had met him multiple times i had
also met him when mikey monsoor
when when his parents were given mikey's
medal of honor at the white house like
mike thornton was there we we talked we
hung out we drank beers like i know him
and
i had never
gotten any kind of a debrief
about
the the operation where he ended up
receiving the medal of honor until he
came on the podcast and gave us up to
our full detailed debrief
on
why he
received the medal of honor
so it's the same thing here
like i had known
that
admiral richards was you know a badass
vietnam guy that's you know that's just
there's a whole category when you're a
new guy and the teams in the 90s there's
just like a whole there's a whole group
yeah and it's just like oh yeah a nom
guy
and you're not in that group or even
close to it because now it's 1991 when
i'm checking in vietnam's been over for
a long time
but that that that's the that's the
group and you don't know too much about
him
you don't understand you couldn't
debrief like the debrief that he went
through today how awesome is that it's
it's just hey here's exactly what
happened here's what was going on here's
what i said
here's the words that came out of my
mouth here's the here's what the other
individual here's where the helicopter
just hearing these details
and understanding them it's just so i'm
so lucky to be sitting here
yeah this though the whole time
these thoughts flash in my head like
okay imagine if you're like a you know a
vc guy or you know
nba guy
and you for whatever reason
get face to face with this [ __ ]
right here
let's say i don't know you guys lost all
your weapons whatever and now you got to
go hand to hand you're surrendering till
the death you're surrendering with this
like the most hard the most hardened the
most hardened nva
like just warrior he's surrendering he's
just like hey i'm done bro forget the
wrestling kid who got body slammed in a
concussion forget that guy bro this guy
is going
down yeah you're going down like you can
tell and you could you know he threw his
numbers out right i mean he's throwing
out his numbers oh yeah but you can just
tell too some people are strong yeah
like they're just genetically freaking
strong and by the way when you're 14
years old after your freshman year and
you weigh 140 pounds and the
170 pound wrestling coach comes out and
can't hold you down and you're not that
good of a wrestler yeah but you're just
doing it on pure power you're one of
those dudes
you are just a strong
jacked
dude it's not even just jack it's like
the genetic that that dense
just strong freaking
muscle yeah and he's just made of that
just made it at 100 checking in the buds
at 145 by the way
oh sorry 245
i got a little confused there because i
checked in the buds at 174
like a little baby
like a little baby and it wasn't like i
was a skinny guy you know i wasn't
skinny but our damn sure wasn't
245 pounds deadlifting over five
benching over four i mean come on yeah
then
if you're a random
vietcong fighter that you've been raised
in the fields and eating rice and you
weigh
he was just saying after the podcast
he's like yeah you know the average
vietnamese fighter was he's i think he
said five five
135 yeah that's the average fighter
that's literally the size of my wife
yeah and so we are talking about just
that what what
the hulk
it's like the moon it's like being the
actual hulk he grabs a hold of you and
starts shaking your head around yeah
so
you know that's enjoy i remember the
story so if you're saying like oh when
you're in the weight room yeah you know
the the hulk comes in yeah you know and
you'll turn it down yeah i'm a new guy
man yeah you know that's interesting
plus the other thing that's interesting
is
i thought you know who is this old guy
right and in my mind he was a hundred
years old because he was a nom you know
and um you know how old he was i did the
math he was he was like 43 or 44. he was
six or seven years younger than i am
right now
and and i'm in there thinking i like in
my mind i think this guy doesn't know
what rock and roll music is you know
and it's just so ignorant it's so
ignorant meanwhile he's about
he was just telling you he's like a
bouncer at this bar hucking people on
their head he's the freaking bruiser
dude i wanted i should have talked to
him about that yeah you know i have a
bouncing background yeah maybe we could
have shared you guys have like that big
kinship yeah
i'm sure his uh
his time as a bouncer might might have
been more robust than mine probably yeah
and well that's you know when you when
you ask him about lifting and still
lifting like such a key component of
life is just to keep exercising yeah
because i mean what do you say he was 74
years old
yes
yeah yeah i mean he rolled in here to
date with no i mean you just until
totally perfect health yeah
and you know shook my hand you know you
the the handshake is kind of a little
subliminal warning of just what could
happen you know he's kind of like look
you might think you're tough they're
young jocko but uh you know you know you
want to play
yeah and i didn't and i was doing the
math when he told me the year he was
born during the break and i i was
surprised i thought i thought maybe like
oh yeah maybe 60 something you know
because just you know you can just tell
guys like just yeah energy you know and
their energy yeah so but my estimate was
way off so yeah man and that and that
was his thing too like obviously like he
was saying like yeah running wasn't my
jam or whatever it was just straight up
lifting yeah not
literally nothing else really i mean
unless i missed something
he was just shacky steel yeah
and plus wrestling
yeah wrestling for sure
this is you know a good skill to have
it's kind of the jam when when the judo
navy ju all navy judo champion comes
running out of a hooch on a training off
and you got a double leg
uh good stuff uh well hey thanks
everybody for listening and we
appreciate you hanging out if you if
there's look you won't probably want a
jack steal after you listen to hulk i
know i'm kind of feeling like i want to
go dead lift something right now yes me
too yeah probably going to need some
supplementation you might as well get
some yep get get a little bit of that
jackal fuel dragonfield.com
that's the clean one
it's a big deal it is a big deal so we
got energy drinks yeah let's go jocko go
uh we got some protein tastes good and
clean and it's clean protein no
sugar that's called milk yep
all that stuff you can get at
jackoful.com the the
if you want to get the drinks you can
get them at wawa
you can also get all the stuff at
vitamin shop we're in the process of
going into so many more stores right now
it's awesome i'll keep you posted on
that on where you can go to your local
neighborhood and get your get your jocko
fuel together so that's good and you
might have seen recently we started
talking about the hunting hunting
apparel we did a little live last night
a little live was it live instagram
streaming live
sure yeah so we did that yesterday what
was the uh
was the takeaway on that sorry to say i
didn't catch it you know but
what was it i guess you're gonna have to
go back and review your tapes yeah all
right that's why
that's why i shared it or whatever i
understand fully that's why i shared it
obviously the the players on there
campaigns yep
who else roberts
kip folks so where we started a company
origin hunt
and we're going to be making
american-made hunting gear
kip folks has a massive amount of
experience he
was one of the original guys at under
armour yeah
and so he has done all kinds of product
development and
one of the main guys that they sponsored
well actually the longest guy sponsored
at under armour was cam haynes
and cam haynes is obviously a legendary
uh bowhunter
so
they had a relationship and
yeah things there was an opportunity cam
was going through whatever he was going
through
at under armour so we had an opportunity
to
form a company together all of us and
it's funny i saw somebody wrote like oh
oh i'm glad to see cam's whatever the
first ambassador for origin hunt and the
fact is no he's not an ambassador of
origin hunt he's a founding a founding
owner of origin hunt so it's a totally
cool thing for
for us to be a part of and and and
listen
i know it seems a little bit crazy i i
know you might think i'm a little bit
like oh you're going a little whatever
right
when i say to you that hey
we're in an economic war and people go
oh yeah yeah they get it but here's the
thing it's like
it's like one of those things that's not
in front of your face so you don't worry
about it yeah right yeah it's like oh
there's something wrong with our with
our sewer pipe under the house yeah and
you're like okay but as long as it
doesn't stink you're not you're not
calling the plumber right it's like the
check engine like
yeah it's like the check engine light
but it kind of flickers on and it goes
off it goes
on it goes off and it flickers on it
goes off i'm telling you i'm the check
engine light right now for the world
and i'm telling you right now the check
engine light is on it should be on and
you need to get in the game because
that's what's going that's what's
happening we're in an economic war with
china and the more we
blow it off and act like it's no big
deal and keep driving the car keep
flushing the toilet down the sewer pipe
we're gonna look up and that thing's
gonna burst
and it's gonna be [ __ ] everywhere
so and your car's gonna break down so
let's not do that
this is american-made stuff
originusa.com this is american-made
stuff it's the everything about it is
american-made
so get in the game that's what we're
doing we're making work where we're
making jiu jitsu gear we're making
hunting gear guess what guess what i
need in my life jiu jitsu gear hunting
gear workwear
if um and i'm not joking by the way with
this uh
so i saw a i don't know if it was a
sample or just one of the the pants
right for hunting so that looks like
something i would wear i don't go
hunting yeah as of yet okay yeah and i
don't know if i am or not but as of
right now i am desire to have i am
currently not hunting about that yeah
yeah yeah it's one of those things for
sure but when i say it's one of those
things it's one of those things
yes so i don't know am i going to get
there yes maybe maybe not anyway
the question is what if i just wear them
anyway is that posing i mean tech i'm
not i'm not doing it i wouldn't be
wearing these hunting pants to make like
i'm a hunter one of the things one of my
philosophies of life is you you want to
have multiple purposes for everything
that you have
so even like delta jeans
they're cool to wear if you want to go
to a restaurant with your wife they're
also cool if you have to just go do
squats in or you do yard work in right
that's the kind of flexibility you have
you want to make things that have
multi-purpose
capabilities so
the the
clothing that we're making for origin
hunt will be multi-purpose and if you're
in an urban scenario where things are
unfolding and you just happen to be
rolling deep echo charles style with a
pair of camis sure no one's going to
give you a second look other than the
gold man those things look legit okay
good yeah so i think you're good i'm
clearing you hot okay so even if there's
no scenario unfolding the only thing
that you would have to use caution in in
my opinion with originusa.com
is if you didn't train jiu jitsu at all
but you thought the geese looked cool
and you just went out and got one and
you were wearing it down to the club
that makes sense to me i wouldn't do
that okay that would be posing okay yes
but if you happen to if you happen to
reach in the freaking cupboard and you
pulled out a pair of
freaking camo origin pants
then you were like hey this is what i'm
wearing i think we're good wait but the
camel
because hunting camo is different than
reggae like right now i'm literally
wearing camel pants as in while we're
wearing camo shorts right and we're not
fighting in the jungle right now we're
not or not could be
we're ready if we need to maybe later
yeah either way
you know no one's gonna be like oh er
like thinking that i'm actually trying
to act like i'm actually doing xyz in
the jungle no one is mistaking you for a
commando exactly right it's like
no one's mistaking you for
for a jungle warrior right correct yes
so do i am i extended that same sort of
courtesy or latitude i'm telling you
you're good and because of the materials
that we're using to make this stuff
you're going to want to where you're
going to be this will become the
standard kind of i think there's many
people all over america just we're going
to the grocery store in origin hunt camo
that's what i was calling it's going to
be a thing that's what i was planning on
yeah because and i'm only i didn't even
feel them i saw a picture of them and i
know i know good pants when i see them
mm-hmm
like with a cupcake you got that
you've got that gut instinct that's
always been good you know well you know
some people got it some people got that
special talent so yeah
originusa.com hey if you want to get
some cool of the
kind what would you say like the things
we you and i have said on the podcast
yeah you get some jacquard store.com
stuff like t-shirt yeah okay well you
know of course i always say how to
represent on the path and the reason why
i always say it like that yeah is
because that's the best way to say
it okay
it's not the best way to say it no no no
tell me what you do no no no no no
apparently it's not i don't know
apparently it is because you say so okay
all right well in my opinion should i
leave now current
you want me to go because i don't want
to see i don't want to get in the way of
your freaking awesome it feels the most
accurate how about that okay okay
in one of his moves today okay all right
no no that's good that's good um
either way
if you want to represent while you're on
the path when i'm on the path and i wear
this shirt i am currently representing
i'm in the in in the middle of
representing while on the path okay i'm
saying right now you're in the middle of
over explaining something no no no in
the spirit of accuracy and consistency
and thoroughness
throwing this yeah i'm explaining that's
how cool so it's better it's a benefit
either way jacostore.com that's where
you can get this stuff good apparel
good apparel fits good looks good yup
just subscribe to the podcast check out
jockowunderground.com
that's where we're we got an alternative
site in case we need it you know the
deal if you want to support us there
we're putting out an extra podcast for
you some extra information
it's eight dollars and eighteen cents a
month if you can't afford it
look if you can't afford it you can
email assistance underground dot at
jocko underground.com
also check your situation check your
situation because if you if eight
dollars and 18 cents a month if that's
putting a negative impact on your zone
then check it out you need to do some
assessment of where you're at because
that's not where you want to be
so
go back and start listing the podcast at
one we're gonna go through all kinds of
things they're gonna help get you to a
point where you're like eight dollars
and eighteen cents a month to provide
freedom to the world we're in
that's my recommendation there
uh
youtube channel we got a youtube channel
subscribe to that subscribe to the us
origin usa youtube channel flip side
canvas dakota meyer
scott i was gonna bring up something
about dakota today oh you know what's
gonna bring up dakota but i just didn't
was when
admiral richards was talking about first
responders dude
dakota is a first responder right now
yeah like not not like oh he does like
uh training for them no no i'm saying
right now
he's a first responder dakota meyer is
currently right now probably out
fighting a fire helping somebody
medically in a car accident
but he man he it's it's a freaking
insane hard job and i'll give you an
example and i i don't want to i'll give
you a
i'll paraphrase a conversation i had
with dakota the other day
they pull up to it they pull up to a
site
that they they pull up to a call it's a
suicide
it's a
young
it's a teenage child
who has committed suicide by hanging
themselves
and
i think
dakota said something like you know like
as we're pulling up and i'm starting to
get out of the vehicle like the person
i'm with whoever he's with is more
experienced person
and they're like hey grab the bolt
cutters
and
he was like
okay and he grabs the bolt cutters
because that person knew that they were
gonna have to cut them down and that was
like the easiest way
so
yeah all the first responders out there
man um we appreciate what you're doing
and the that's dakota meyer and this
dakota meyer who
is not only a u.s marine not only a
medal of honor recipient not only a
freaking awesome guy but he's also
currently at this time
a
firefighter emt paramedic dude that
sends me pictures at one o'clock in the
morning of him responding to a car
accident a house fire a freaking medical
emergency
so
god bless that guy and go check out
flipsidecampus.com
buy some cool stuff to hang on your wall
which is what it is i forgot to tell you
that that's what you know what it
doesn't really matter if if i was like
hey he's selling cottage cheese and
and and freaking uh clay bowls i'd be
like cool go buy some cottage i want
some cottage cheese down some clay bowls
that's what we're doing
dakota
flipside canvas.com hey i read a bunch
of books check those out
uh
ashland front leadership consultancy
if you need help inside your
organization
go to ashlandfront.com
we got some live events coming up
you know we got coming up we got the
battlefield
ef battlefield
and we take and we go and walk
historical battlefields we do gettysburg
we do
little bighorn
so
go and check that out we just go
site by sight we walk where the where
the leaders walked where the troops
walked we we
discussed their decisions the good
decisions the bad decisions
it's that's a smaller group right yeah
it's like
25 30 people oh yeah so and it's two
days and you know we like have dinner
and hang out have lunch all those things
so hey look if you want to go there and
you also want to ask about
hey here's a leadership challenge i'm
facing here's what i'm doing with my
company that's cool too
and those answers that we give will many
times be
given with the overlay of hey here's a
historical battle here's what this
general did in this particular case
here's what this colonel did over here
here's what this
this
freaking war chief did over here
so
if you want to come and check any of
that stuff out go to
echelonfront.com look for events we also
have an online training academy
called the academy
extremeownership.com
look
you got to go to the gym if you want to
stay in shape
if you want to improve if you want to
learn guitar you got to practice
if you want to learn a language like
spanish because you're going to el
salvador because the person that you're
replacing just got assassinated there
and you're the only person that rogers
up to go do it and you gotta learn
spanish you gotta go practice it you
gotta get taught it leadership's the
same way and it doesn't happen overnight
you got to learn it you got to study it
so we have the academy
extremeownership.com and listen guess
what leadership is leadership is life
whatever you're doing in your life
you have to set goals you have to figure
out what tasks you need to complete you
need to prioritize and execute how
you're going to make something happen
how you're going to get that house
bought
how are you going to pick up a new job
how are you going to go
rebuild this relationship with someone
that you hurt like those are all things
that we do those are all leadership
things they might not sound like it
leadership is life
so
extreme ownership.com yeah it's about
leadership but don't think to yourself
well you know i'm not really in a
leadership position so i guess it's not
for me you're in a leadership position
you are in a leadership position if
you're the if you're the most junior
person
working at wendy's
if you're the the grill guy at wendy's
which was my job by the way when i was
younger
if you're the that guy
you're you're you're flipping burgers at
wendy's which i did you're in a
leadership position
and you can build relationships with the
people there and you can start to figure
out how things work and you can get
promoted you can move up you can buy
your own store that's what happens by
the way
when you're the most junior person if
you become a leader if you think like a
leader that's what you can do with your
life and it just doesn't apply to work
you want to build a relationship with
another person
that you're in a leadership position i
this might sound uh cold
but guess what you have a wife or you
have a husband you're in a leadership
position
the way you interact with them the
techniques that i use when i'm talking
to you echo charles as my work compadre
are the same techniques that i use when
i'm talking to my wife when i'm talking
to my kids
they're it's human interaction yeah
so if you need help with that
which by the way we all do because
you're not born with it you're not born
look can you be a born leader in yeah
yes you can can you be kind of
charismatic yes you can the best leaders
still make mistakes they still have room
to improve and people that maybe don't
aren't blessed with that natural
leadership gift
guess what
you got room to improve too
there was a there was guys totally
sleeping in my mind right now where um
admiral tom richards was saying
he didn't ever raise his voice like he
never heard him raise his voice but
everyone listened to him al huey yes
okay so it's like okay so consider that
phenomenon like in life where where
essentially you're you have this crazy
and when you think about it's crazy this
ability to navigate through all kinds of
different personalities and they all
get on board with the program get on
board like basically you know how to
make everyone do what they want to do
for themselves or the group or whatever
even and a lot of times that's the part
that i think maybe kind of
goes over my head even where it's like
it's not just
what i'm trying to make the whole group
do sometimes it's just one person in
fact most of the time it's just one
other person in many different
situations or whatever but it's like
yeah it's your brother your wife your
friend or whatever yeah and you can
navigate no matter the personality you
can navigate and control the scenario
for everyone you know for everyone's
interest that's like a superpower and
you know what else is interesting is as
you go through life the more you
understand these concepts you see them
everywhere
you seem and the reason i s what made me
think of that is when you said you know
wife this you mentioned wife you
mentioned like
peers you're mentioning all people that
you're close to that that you interact
with yeah when you go and walk into a
restaurant that you've never been in
before and you interact with the hostess
yeah
that person that's gonna get you a table
there's a leadership situation happening
directly directly hidden not the kind of
like oh if you really like it it's
really happening it's right there and
you might get you might get like put oh
yeah yes come have a seat over here sir
and you get put by the kitchen and
there's noise coming out there may be
some
background uh smells that you're not
particularly fond of that can happen
right there and you can also get point
put
in the window seat overlooking the ocean
that is a leadership scenario yeah and
if you know how to interact with other
human beings
you're going to end up by the window
you're going to end up overlooking the
ocean not with the racket from the
kitchen coming out
you see what i'm saying yes
so go to extreme ownership.com let's get
you over at with the ocean view at the
restaurant
let's get you in that situation where
you're not having to raise your voice
like al huey and people are doing what
you want them to do because they want to
do it because they understand what it is
we're trying to do as a team
go to extremeownership.com
and also if you want to help service
members
active and retired if you want to help
people that have served in the military
that need help mark lee's mom mama lee
she's got an incredible charity
organization
she helps people so much
so much if you want to help her help
people you want to help her help
veterans you want to help her help gold
star families go to
americasmightywarriors.org
so you can either volunteer or donate or
help out somehow also check out
heroesandhorses.com
what's up with
what's up with micah micah fink just i
don't know what he's doing right now
at this moment but he's probably
wrestling a grizzly bear
shooing a horse or like capturing uh or
maybe he's sitting in a sweat lodge
hallucinating about like
uh
what does he hallucinate about about
calves
traffic light traffic lights no that was
me so there you go just an awesome
program check that out
and if you need more of us well you know
where we are again do i want you to go
and just sign up for the algorithm and
put a put a a freaking carabiner around
your your heart
and hook it into the algorithm and have
it ripped out no i don't want you to do
that i don't want you to do that but if
you want to be
if you want to know what we're doing
check it out but don't let the check it
out turn into carabiner around your
heart that's what i'm saying watch out
for that that's the social media
platforms that are out there they got
carabiners they're giving them away they
they want you to take that carabiner
they want you to put they're like and
for some reason you think it's cool
you're like oh look at this shiny
character like you give a little yeah
look give a little kid a mousetrap
that's rigged to blow
they're gonna pick it up and get rocked
by it they think they were doing the
right thing curiosity so watch out for
that man the gram
the facebook the twitter
echoes that equal charles
i am out john williams and thanks once
again
to admiral thomas richards
for coming by for sharing his
experiences we
by the way unfortunately as soon as we
hit stop and we started talking he's
like told me
14 more freaking awesome stories about
his experiences about nam about what
they were doing what they're wearing so
we'll get him back on again
but thanks for coming on thanks for your
service admiral and and
once again thanks for for taking care of
me as a young
young seal trying to do better
and thanks for setting a great example
for
the young seals on how to be
badass frogmen and to the rest of the
military folks out there
thank you for your service
in protecting freedom and our way of
life around the world well what did
admiral richards keep saying
7
24
365 days
a year
you're out there
you're out there
so thank you
and thanks to our police and law
enforcement all the firefighters
paramedics emts dispatchers correctional
officers border patrol secret service
all the first responders
you guys are just out there
putting it on the line every day
so we appreciate
what you do as well
and everyone else out there
listen
i'm a little at risk for saying this
because i talk about things like the
indirect approach and i say you should
think through your situations and i
say you should make iterative decisions
about what you're doing so you're taking
small steps to move in the right
direction i say those things all the
time because that's what i want you to
do
99.9 percent of the times that's what i
want you to do but occasionally on the
rare occasion
when things get bad you have to do what
admiral tom richards told his wounded
machine gunner to do in a rice paddy in
vietnam and that is shut up and return
fire
that's all i've got
until next time this is echo and jocko
out